monsieur le ministre comme vous le voyez
la commission est prête à se mettre au
travail dans tous les domaines nous
avons déjà bien entamé nos travaux avec
le projet de loi relatif au pouvoir
d'achat et nous vous consacrons ce soir
notre toute première audition en ce
début de législature donc c'est vraiment
un honneur de vous accueillir monsieur
le ministre cette audition devait
d'ailleurs avoir lieu mardi dernier mais
il n'aurait pas été souhaitable qu'elle
se déroule effectivement en même temps
que l'examen en séance publique du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui s'est prolongée d'ailleurs un peu
plus tard que prévu donc je vous
remercie bien sûr d'avoir répondu
présent et d'avoir bien voulu bien sûr
reporté d'une semaine notre audition
nous recevrons bien sûr très rapidement
vos collègues en charge du travail et
des solidarités
mais l'unanimité s'est faite pour vous
entendre aussi rapidement que possible
en particulier sur la situation des
services d'urgence cet été donc en cet
été 2010 22 plus de deux ans après
l'arrivée d'une pandémie qui a mis à
rude épreuve nos concitoyens et
l'ensemble du système sanitaire votre
prédécesseur madame brigitte bourguignon
vous avez confié une mission flash sur
les urgences et les soins programmés
dont vous avez remis fin juin les
conclusions comprenant 40 et une
recommandation pour l'été vous est
indéniablement le mieux placé à la fois
pour nous présenter ce travail pour nous
dire comment le gouvernement entend en
tirer les conséquences et pour nous
indiquer qu'elles sont au delà bien sûr
de cet été les pistes pour une
amélioration structurelle de
l'organisation de ces soi après bien sûr
votre intervention je donnerai la parole
à la rapporteure générale
stéphanie rice puis aux orateurs des
groupes pour deux minutes mes chers
collègues deux minutes chacun et enfin
aux autres députés également pour deux
minutes et je tiens à vous le dire les
questions sont très nombreuses je passe
toutefois la parole tout de suite à
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente fadila
khattabi madame la rapporteure générale
stéphanie rist mesdames messieurs les
députés
je suis très honoré d'être devant la
commission des affaires sociales pour
cette première audition et pour aborder
un sujet que je connais bien et qui est
au coeur des préoccupations de nos
concitoyens les urgences mais pas que
je tiens à le dire d'emblée nos urgences
sont le symptôme aigu d'une crise plus
large qui traverse le système de santé
en amont des urgences avec la question
du partage de la permanence des soins en
aval avec la question des difficultés à
ouvrir les lie aujourd'hui faute de
personnel toute analyse qui n'iraient
pas dans cette vision large manquerait
certainement le sujet cet été les
difficultés que rencontrent les urgences
prennent une acuité bien particulière
dans les suites de la crise sanitaire
qui a éprouvé notre pays et nos
soignants depuis plus de deux ans ce
n'est pas un phénomène propre à la
france il s'observe ailleurs
la crise tout à la fois redonner du sens
au travail des soignants ont ce qu'ils
étaient tous polariser sur un objectif
de prise en charge des personnes malades
mais aussi mis en exergue les fragilités
de notre système ces fragilités tiennent
à des tensions importantes notamment au
plan de la démographie médicale elles
tiennent aussi à des mouvements société
au plus profond notamment s'agissant de
la pénibilité du travail qui est moins
bien acceptée aujourd'hui qu'hier
ces fragilités nous devons les regarder
en face je ne serai pas le ministre qui
niera les réalités je souhaite les
qualifiés trouver des solutions et
évaluer cette dernière ces dernières
pour que notre effort soit le plus
efficace possible pour la réponse aux
besoins des français
alors avant d'en venir aux sujets qui va
nous occuper aujourd'hui je voudrais
poser les bases de l'ambition qui est la
mienne en tant que ministre de la santé
de la prévention
mon objectif sera de fonder un nouveau
modèle pour répondre toujours mieux aux
besoins de santé de nos concitoyens
partout sur le territoire aujourd'hui et
demain le mot d'ordre est simple il
s'agit de passer d'une logique de
l'offre qui tend à devenir concurrentiel
un système fondé sur la réponse aux
besoins de la population
un système fondé sur le besoin c'est en
somme un système qui se place du point
de vue du soigner et de son entourage
pour à la fois mieux prévenir mieux
dépister mieux soigner et mieux
accompagner oui mieux prévenir également
car je souhaite que nous puissions
développer une culture de la prévention
prévenir et dépister plus précocément
les pathologies c'est agir pour une vie
en meilleure santé et je pense en
particulier aux personnes les plus
modestes pour qui il est souvent
difficile plus difficile de prévenir que
de guérir
cette oeuvre de refondation sera un
travail collectif qui demandera un
certain courage et qui devra associer
aux côtés de l'état les soignants les
soigner et les élus c'est l'objet de la
conférence des parties prenantes de nous
préparons les contours cet été pour un
lancement à la rentrée
et laura naturellement vocation à vous
associer et je me réjouis de la création
de votre groupe de travail sur l'accès
aux soins et je pense que nous aurons à
coeur de travailler ensemble et de plus
vite possible pour trouver des solutions
je me tiens donc prêt à travailler avec
vous au delà des étiquettes politiques
avec l'ensemble de notre représentation
nationale pour faire avancer cette cause
qui je le sais nous tient tous à coeur
les français exigent que nous avancions
il est temps
je suis donc heureux d'être devant vous
pour parler du plan et et des urgences
et des soins non programmés qui est issu
de la mission qui m'avait été confiée
par ma prédécesseure madame brigitte
bourguignon mais avant toute chose je
tiens à couper court à tout débat
l'accès aux urgences pour ceux qui en
ont besoin est garanti je réfute le
terme de tri et je refuse surtout la
philosophie qui est sous-entendu par
ceux qui utilisent ce terme de manière
malveillante je vous le garantis chaque
français continuera à être pris en
charge là où c'est nécessaire
vous le savez sans doute je suis
moi-même un sergent this de profession
comment penser que je peux vouloir autre
chose que soigner au mieux tous les
français selon leur besoin et c'est
précisément ce terme qui compte le
besoin pour que chacun nous aussi nos
concitoyens pardon soit soigné de la
manière la plus adaptée la plus efficace
l'orientation en fonction du besoin de
chacun est primordial je tiens à
insister sur ce point l'orientation ce
n'est pas une dégradation de l'accès aux
soins c'est au contraire une meilleure
organisation notre système de santé au
service des patients
c'est tout l'état d'esprit du plan que
je suis venu vous présenter aujourd'hui
pour élaborer cette boîte à outils pour
l'été j'ai eu à coeur d'aller sur le
terrain d'aller voir ce qui marchait et
ceux qui ne fonctionnaient pas je peux
vous dire que des solutions durables et
innovantes émergent chaque jour porté
par des professionnels engagés et qui
ont la même passion de leur métier
chevillée au corps je m'en suis beaucoup
inspiré
alors vous le savez sans doute la boîte
à outils que nous proposons est riche de
nombreuses mesures afin de permettre aux
urgences de travailler mieux cet été les
territoires dispose ainsi jusqu'à la fin
du mois de septembre d'une série de
nouveaux leviers pour garantir une
réponse adaptée aux besoins de santé des
français tout au long de l'été ces
mesures sont nombreuses parfois assez
technique
je vais donc concentré mon propos sur
quelques grandes mesures structurantes
et je serai à votre disposition pour
détailler l'ensemble des autres tout
d'abord comme tout soignants je veux
commencer par confirmer un diagnostic
qui a déjà été posée avant la crise par
les rapports de jean yves grall et en
2019 de thomas régnier et pierre carli
les urgences sont le point de
convergence des difficultés de la ville
et de l'hôpital par conséquent elles ne
sont que le révélateur d'une crise plus
profonde qui touche l'ensemble du
système démographie médicale inadaptée
offre de soins inadéquats mauvaise
articulation entre l'amont la médecine
de ville laval l'hôpital déserts
médicaux perte de sens et d'attractivité
de certains métiers du soin les urgences
sont en quelque sorte la partie émergée
de l'iceberg
oui pour beaucoup les urgences
apparaissent comme le seul recours c'est
un problème car cette situation mine la
capacité du système tout entier à bien
traiter les patients qui ont réellement
besoin du plateau technique des urgences
redonner à chacun son rôle c'est
permettre aux patients de mieux être
soigné et se permettent aux
professionnels de santé de faire leur
travail efficacement et sereinement
alors face à ce défi quelles sont les
solutions que nous proposons pour que
nos concitoyens puissent être
correctement accueilli cet été notre
première priorité je vous le disais
c'est de mieux orienter les malades en
amont pour cela nous devons avoir un mot
d'ordre simple l'appel aux urgences
le numéro 15 doit devenir un réflexe
pour tous les français en cas de
détresse bien sûr mais aussi lorsque
devant une situation aiguë leur médecin
traitant n'est pas gagné ce numéro doit
permettre d'orienter le patient selon ce
besoin ce besoin pouvant être ou ne pas
être d'aller se faire soigner aux
urgences car ce n'est pas aux patients
de porter la responsabilité de savoir si
son symptôme est une urgence ou pas
pour faire du 15e réflexe des messages
pédagogiques sont diffusés sur les
radios notamment relayé par les ars pour
informer et inciter les français à y
recourir avant de se déplacer à
l'hôpital au bout du fil les français
trouveront soit le samu soit un service
d'accès aux soins plus large que nous
entendons continuer à développer au delà
des 22 sites pilotes pour orienter le
patient inverse la meilleure solution
disponible la plus adaptée à son besoin
de soins en parallèle nous encourageons
le recrutement des assistants de
régulation médicale les armes qui ont
vocation d'armé ce dispositif
d'orientation et d'orienter vers un
médecin régulateur urgentiste ou
généraliste pour traiter la pelle nous
simplifions également et améliorons la
rémunération des médecins libéraux qui
participent à la régulation au sein du
service d'accès aux soins
notre deuxième priorité c'est en aval de
libérer des capacités d'accueil en soins
non programmés la mobilisation solidaire
de la ville et de l'hôpital est en effet
indispensable pour désengorger les
urgences pour cela nous avons décidé
d'attribuer de manière temporaire un
supplément de 15 euros pour tout acte
effectué par un médecin libéral à la
demande de la régulation du samu ou du
sas pour un patient hors patientèle
majoration de 15 euros existant déjà
pour les patients de la propre
patientèle les médecins nous ont dit que
les modalités de valorisation de leur
participation aux consultations orientée
par le saas ou le samu était un frein à
leurs engagements nous simplifions et
améliorons notre soutien à eux de nous
montrer que c'est utile et vecteur d'une
mobilisation renforcée au service des
français de leur territoire
l'objectif est d'inciter les médecins à
libérer des plages horaires pour
l'accueil de ces patients qui n'ont pas
forcément vocation à être pris en charge
aux urgences
enfin notre troisième priorité c'est
d'encourager le déploiement d'une offre
cohérente de soins sur l'ensemble du
territoire oui la clé pour que nos
concitoyens soient soignés rapidement et
de manière adéquate c'est un bon
maillage et une bonne articulation qui
mobilise efficacement l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé d'un territoire
libéraux comme hospital les publics
comme privés médecins comme paramédicaux
pour ce faire les mesures sont
nombreuses et la possibilité de
mobiliser les ambulanciers pour conduire
des patients vers un cabinet de médecine
libérale ou une maison médicale de garde
ou les expérimentations relatives à la
télémédecine et au suivi médical à
distance nous facilitant également les
admissions directes en service
hospitalier l'hébergement d'urgence en
ehpad et le recours à l'hospitalisation
à domicile
plus largement l'organisation de la
permanence des soins en établissement de
santé doit se faire à l'échelle du
territoire nous demandons donc à ce que
les spécialistes privés comme publics
soient associés sous la coordination de
l' agence régionale de santé concernés
car la pénibilité de la nuit et du week
end ne toi ne doit ne peut plus reposer
que sur le service public
voilà quelques-unes des mesures les plus
significatives que nous mettons en place
avec ce plan je n'oublie pas non plus la
pénibilité du travail de tous les
professionnels engagés la nuit dans nos
établissements publics
ces femmes et ces hommes font un travail
difficile et courageux
nous avons donc eu à coeur de renforcer
la reconnaissance de cette pénibilité
particulière en doublant les majorations
de nuit pour les personnels soignants et
en valorisant revalorisant de 50% des
gares pour les médecins pour une durée
de trois mois
aujourd'hui la mise en oeuvre de ce plan
est bien lancée vous le savez il s'agit
de mesures temporaires jusqu'à fin
septembre qui permettront aux services
d'urgences partout en france de passer
l'été autant que possible fait donc
adressé une instruction aux agences
régionales de santé et à l'ensemble des
services de l'état le 10 juillet dernier
pour leur demander de veiller au
déploiement rapide des leviers qu'ils
estimeront les plus adaptées à leur
territoire les textes ont été pris pour
offrir les souplesse nécessaires à la
sécurisation de la réponse estivale
toutefois j'insiste à nouveau là dessus
la réussite de ces mesures reposent sur
un engagement collectif c'est pourquoi
j'ai également demandé aux ars
d'associer autant que possible
l'ensemble des acteurs à la mise en
oeuvre de ce plan d'urgence à savoir les
préfets les élus locaux les
professionnels de santé ou encore les
représentants des patients et de leurs
familles enfin naturellement une fois ce
plan mener à bien il nous faudra en
tirer toutes les leçons c'est la raison
pour la paix laquelle l'impact de ces
mesures les français sera précisément
évalué mesurer tout au long de l'été
c'est seulement par la suite que nous
envisagerons la pérennisation ou la
généralisation de certaines de ces
mesures selon les résultats qu'elles
auront permis d'obtenir dans la même
logique des mesures qui n'auraient pas
été efficaces ne seront pas pérennisés
c'est dans cette optique que j'installe
très prochainement le comité de suivi et
d'évaluation de ce plan d'urgence
afin de construire une vision
véritablement partagée ce comité
associera aussi divers acteurs des
patients des professionnels de santé
mais aussi les services de l'état et les
élus ce sera aussi l'occasion de se
projeter dans la future réforme du
système de santé et de nourrir les
futurs travaux de la conférence des
parties prenantes souhaitée par le
gouvernement
en somme le plan dont je suis venu vous
parler aujourd'hui est un plan d'urgence
mais c'est aussi une première pierre
posée pour refonder et renforcer notre
système de santé nous en tirerons toutes
les leçons et je me réjouis d'y
travailler avec vous dans les mois qui
viennent je ne doute pas que nous serons
être au rendez vous de ce défi collectif
je vous remercie
merci bien monsieur le ministre donc
avant de passer la parole aux
représentants des groupes politiques je
passe la parole à madame stéphanie rist
notre rapporteur général merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre tient
tout d'abord à vous féliciter pour votre
nomination gouvernement et pour la
qualité des travaux vous avez récemment
conduit sur la situation des urgences et
qui permet d'avoir une véritable boîte à
outils à utiliser sur notre territoire
vous soulignez que pour désengorger les
services d'urgence un enjeu clé est de
parvenir à fluidifier les sorties
d'urgence en d'autres termes c'est
souvent l'aval des urgences qui pèche
c'est en réalité assez banal de trouver
dans les services d'urgences de très
nombreux patients qui ne relèvent plus
ou pas vraiment de l'urgence ces
patients se trouvent la faute de lit
adapté à leur prise en charge nous le
savons bien souvent ces patients sont
des personnes âgées pour lequel nous ne
parvenons pas à proposer une prise en
charge adaptée que ce soit en
établissement ou à domicile
je pense que nous devons absolument dès
l'automne prochain agir sur cet enjeu de
l'aval des urgences pour les personnes
âgées ce pourra être l'un des objectifs
du groupe de travail sur l'autonomie que
nous avons créés au sein de la
commission dans le but d'identifier des
sujets sur lesquels nous pourrions
avancer dès le prochain plfss
je crois que cette question du parcours
de soin en aval des urgences doit nous
amener à nous interroger plus largement
sur la prise en charge des personnes
âgées dans le contexte du vieillissement
de la population selon l'insee près de 4
millions de seniors en perte d'autonomie
en 2050 c'est-à-dire 60 % de plus qu'en
2015 pour faire face à ce défi
démographique nous savons que nous
devons innover et diversifier les
modalités de prise en charge si nous
voulons que notre système de santé
tiennent le choc à moyen et à long terme
monsieur mines et j'aimerais donc que
vous nous indiquer comment vous pensez
que nous pouvons très rapidement rendre
plus fluides les parcours des soins des
personnes âgées en aval des urgences en
d'autres termes qui et comment
allons-nous soigner les personnes âgées
dans les années qui viennent je vous
remercie merci bien madame la
rapporteure et je vous remercie pour
votre question concise je passe la
parole à présent affres monsieur fredy
certain pour le groupe renaissance
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous sommes ravis de vous
recevoir au sein de cette commission
vous le savez nous sommes toutes et tous
concernés par ce qu'il se passe en
milieu hospitalier et plus largement au
sein de notre système de santé ce depuis
bien des années
si un budget important a été consacré au
déploiement des mesures du pacte de
refondation d urgence à hauteur de 750
millions d'euros jusqu'en 2022 la
pandémie à freiner la mise en oeuvre de
certaines des recommandations et de
nouveaux besoins sont apparus nous
appelons à réagir et agir vite dans ce
contexte c'est dans ce contexte que le
président de la république et la
ministre de la santé de l'époque
brigitte bourguignon vous ont proposé de
mener à bien une mission flash d'un mois
visant à trouver des solutions pour
renforcer l'accès aux soins urgents et
non programmés cet été nous connaissons
votre attachement à la restructuration
de l'offre de soins actuels qui
souffrent de problèmes structurels et de
défaut de coordination et je tenais à
saluer au nom du groupe renaissance la
qualité de la mission que vous avez
menées vos quarante et une proposition
qui ont toutes été retenu par la
première ministre elisabeth bornes pose
les bases d'une consultation beaucoup
plus vaste et territorialisée que vous
lancerez en septembre avec votre avec
notre sous au travers de la conférence
des parties prenantes je pense qu'il est
important pour nous toutes et tous
d'avoir une véritable vision sur ce que
portera cette conférence et comment nous
pouvons dans nos territoires porter les
débats et amener des solutions concrètes
et des financières cette consultation
qui réunira l'ensemble des acteurs de la
santé d'un territoire donné des élus et
sous l'égide de l'état permettra une
concertation objective dépassant les
clivages public-privé et remettant
centre des débats nos concitoyens et
leur souhait d'accéder à des soins de
proximité
au delà des services et des moyens
matériels ce sont surtout nos
professionnels de santé qui méritent
tout notre engagement en adaptant les
effectifs aux organisations et en
reconnaissant la pénibilité de leur
métier dans la tente de cette
concertation certaines agences
régionales de santé ont déjà engagé des
dispositifs avez vous des retours sur ce
sujet enfin pourriez vous nous indiquez
monsieur le ministre quelles sont les
mesures prises pour permettre une
meilleure coopération entre
établissements publics et privés dans la
prise en charge des urgences et
l'orientation pour des prises en charge
médicales et chirurgicales rapide et de
proximité je vous en remercie je vous
remercie cher collègue monsieur victor
cateau pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous avons aujourd'hui le
plaisir vous auditionné et nous avons à
faire notre système de soins est
complètement défaillant nous ne comptons
plus les insuffisances 18000 fermetures
de lits par le président de la
république 30% des postes non pourvus
7,4 millions de français vivent dans un
désert médical mais que fait le
gouvernement pourrions-nous dire qu'il
ne fait rien non mais qu'il fait trop
peu et mal oui il n'y a pas besoin d
illustrer nos propos par cinquante mille
exemples au titre de l'aide de l'année
2020 alors que nous étions en pleine
épidémie de kovy 19 le président de la
république a décidé de fermer cinq mille
700 lits d'hospitalisation complète
c'est-à-dire 5700 lie à destination des
patients qui passent plus d'une journée
à l'hôpital nous fonçons droit dans le
mur et pourtant monsieur le ministre des
propositions nous en avons et vous
pourriez vous en inspirer avec nous le
salaire des infirmiers des personnels
hospitaliers non concernés par le
secteur de la santé sera augmenté pour
atteindre la moyenne européenne avec
nous des places supplémentaires seraient
créés au sein des instituts de formation
en soins infirmiers et des centres de
formation d'aides-soignants avec nous
une gouvernance bicéphale partager
serait instaurée entre les diables
d'hôpital pour les aspects
administratifs et un médecin pour les
questions médicales avec nous les ars
serait supprimé et la tutelle des
hôpitaux seraient confiées à nouveau au
préfet de région ces propositions dont
je me fais le porte pas aujourd'hui
permettrait si elle était adoptée de
fournir à l'hôpital public des moyens
pour être efficace de faire face à
l'épidémie et on manque de
reconnaissance des patients et des
soignants et de considérer les français
avec dignité ce n'est pas parce que vous
avez provoqué l'hémorragie de l'hôpital
public mais chez mini ce qui ne vous ne
pouvez pas la stopper je vous remercie
merci bien madame caroline fiat pour la
france insoumise
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministère collègues en juillet 2019
j'aime j'ai numéraire et à la tribune le
nombre de services d'urgence en grève
dont le chr de metz-thionville que vous
connaissez de me semble monsieur le
ministre la situation était déjà
catastrophique depuis rien n'a changé
tout empire et je pourrai vous faire
désormais l'énumération des services
d'urgence ferme et deux ans de kovy des
des épisodes de canicules à répétition
n'ont bien sûr rien arrangé partout dans
votre rapport on retrouve le champ
lexical de la finance et de la start up
née chaîne optimisation programmation
plus values contractualisation
régulation etc et la palme est attribué
à votre nouveau bad management quand
comprendrez vous que les services
d'urgence n'ont pas être traités comme
la filiale non rentables d'une
entreprise il paraît pourtant que vous
avez été vous même urgentiste dans une
autre vie elle semble bien lointaine les
urgences souffre parce qu'il n'y a pas
de moyens pas de personnel et que vous
ne répondez jamais la problématique des
déserts médicaux votre solution pour que
les urgences fonctionnent mieux se
résume facilement merci de ne pas vous y
rendre monsieur le ministre êtes vous
conscient des conséquences que cela
entraîne vous mettez gravement en danger
la vie des patients vous souhaitez
mesurer mesureront vous avez sûrement
entendu l'histoire de ce couple à qui on
a refusé l'accès aux urgences alors que
leur bébé souffrait de problèmes
respiratoires
ils ont eu la peur de leur vie
aujourd'hui profondément choqués ils
restent traumatisés de cette expérience
heureusement l'histoire s'est bien
terminée mais je me demande monsieur le
ministre qu'auriez vous à leur répondre
si leur parcours du combattant cette
nuit là c'était tragique tragiquement
pardon terminer ma question est simple
êtes vous consciente de l'inhumaine
responsabilité que vous fait peser sur
tous les personnels de ces services qui
à cause de votre politique de casse de
l'hôpital public doivent toujours plus
choisir entre qui sera soigné et qui ne
le sera pas merci bien
monsieur philippe juvin pour les
républicains
monsieur le ministre
vous avez explique vous avez dit alors
que l'accès aux urgences était garantie
si la question n'est pas tant que
l'access de gens soit garanti c'est
heureux la question c'est la qualité de
l'accueil et quand vous étiez
responsables de sociétés savantes vous
aviez mis en place ce qu'on appelait le
nobel challenge qui est une manière de
compter tous les soirs toutes les nuits
les françaises et les françaises qui
dorment sur un brancard dans un service
d'urgence et je me souviens qu'en mars
2018 vous aviez compter dans les trois
premiers mois de l'année jusqu'à 120
mille personnes qui avaient dormi sur un
brancard donc la qualité des soins est
notre priorité c'est pas tant le fait
que les gens soient accueillis encore
une fois cet heureux il ya premièrement
un problème de nombre de médecins
qu'on le veuille ou non la grande
bretagne vient de décider de passer de
10000 à 20000 le nombre de médecins
formés par an pourquoi parce qu'un
médecin formé aujourd'hui ne fait plus
le même travail qu'un médecin formé il
ya trente ans il travaille moins il
travaille différemment et donc il ya un
problème de nombre deuxièmement il ya
une prime de conditions de travail 30 %
des infirmières diplômées d'état cesse
de travailler dans les cinq ans qui
suivent la délivrance de leur diplôme ce
qui montre que vraiment il ya un sujet
de ressources humaines et souvent je
trouve dans les hôpitaux nous avons des
services du personnel mais nous n'avons
pas de service de ressources humaines
ils ne font pas ce travail là est
peut-être pourrions-nous travailler sur
la différenciation dans la rémunération
entre ceux qui travaillent tous les
jours et ceux qui ne travaillent que le
jour la différenciation jour nuit est un
sujet à l'hôpital enfin dernier point
permettez moi de vous poser une question
sur la variole du singe le plus
exactement le plan national de
préparation à une résurgence de la
variole il y avait un plan qui existait
en 2006 il a été mise à jour en 2006 et
depuis on n'en trouve pas trace alors
première question est ce que ce plan
existe dans l'hypothèse d'une retour de
la variole comme maladie qui serait à
visée terroriste bien entendu et à
l'époque le plan disait que la france
disposait de 72 millions de doses et se
fixait comme objectif de pouvoir de
pouvoir vacciner 60 millions de français
en 14 jours donc sommes nous capables
aujourd'hui dans l'hypothèse d'un retour
de l'épidémie à des fins terroristes de
vacciner 60 millions de personnes en 14
jours très bien merci la parole est à
monsieur cyrille isaac sibille pour le
groupe démocrate
merci ma la présidente monsieur mini
chers collègues je souhaiterais en
premier lieu c'est lui le travail que
vous avez menées dans le cadre de la
mission flash les urgences et les soins
non programmés
vous avez apporté un éclairage bienvenu
sur le niveau de tension élevée nos
séries d'urgence ainsi qu'une boîte à
outils et travaille pour remédier aux
difficultés actuelles dans votre rapport
vous faites état dans des visites de
l'offre de soins d'une pénurie de
médecins urgentistes de recours
inapproprié aux séries d'urgence comme
principale cause de la crise actuelle en
dehors des mesures temporaires dont vous
êtes fait part dans le rapport ce
constat nous invite à réfléchir sur le
long terme à la paz en système des soins
non programmés urgent mais pour des
pathologies que l'on sait non vitales
qu'ils n'hésitent cependant un plateau
technique léger pourquoi ce type de soin
pour ce type de soins les patients se
tournent vers les urgences malgré de
longues heures d'attentes d'abord parce
que l'offre de ville n'est pas outillé
pour les soins nos programmes et nos
vies tôt ensuite car les urgences offre
une certaine souplesse et facilité en
l'absence de contrôle horaire enfin car
le patient est certain à l'isi sont en
attente des difficiles examens
complémentaires réalisés sur place deux
points bénéficié d'un avis spécialisés
si nécessaire de pouvoir diagnostic
précis et une prise en charge complète
si nécessaire grâce un peu techniques
dont dispose des structures et qui évite
aux patients de nombreux allers-retours
entre les différents personnels de santé
radiologue laboratoire ali etc monsieur
beneath si ce soir nous sommes victimes
d'une chute entraînant une plaie au
genou et une incapacité à se relever
inexorablement il sera dirigé vers un
service d'urgence alors que la médecine
de ville peut prendre en charge ces
pathologies depuis 2010 9 je défends une
solution travaille avec jean yves grall
processone ont programmé n'engageait pas
le pronostic vital du patient 1 en effet
nous pour pérenniser la mise en place de
structures dédiées à ces prises en
charge grâce une identification une
labellisation c'est ce qu'on avait
appelé les points d'accueil pour soins
immédiats j'existe des gens ce différend
non ce dans différents territoires qui
fonctionnent avec des médecins de ville
qui dispose déjà d'un plateau technique
minimum comprenant un service de
radiologie de biologie de matériels
permettant les soins tels que les futurs
ou les immobilisations
cette provision de loi est adopté par
l'assemblée nationale et dans la navette
parlementaire et des demandes qui est
reprise cela nous permettra réponse de
répondre à la fois la demande forte des
patients et des présentes et mes temps
et en mettant en oeuvre une région
territoriale de la médecine vous ne
captez vite je remercie bien merci bien
monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur arthur de la plante pour le
groupe socialiste et apparentés madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre merci
d'avoir bien voulu organiser cette
audition que nous avions sollicité
nous aurions évidemment mille questions
j'en aurai 2 mai avant de les évoquer je
voudrais
évoquer le cas d'une française parmi des
milliers des centaines de mines et
d'autres parce que le rapport brawn qui
parle de la crise des urgences est
finalement un rapport très technique et
parfois je dirais désincarné qui manque
de chair et moi donc cette habitante de
ma circonscription elle avait elle a
toujours 80 ans elle est atteinte d'un
cancer et la contracter une piano
néphrite la semaine dernière 36 heures
d'angoissé à attendre sur un brancard
dans les urgences au milieu des cris des
patients au milieu des soignants des
médecins compatissant
mais désemparés c'était la semaine
dernière au chu de caen c'était la
semaine dernière
partout en france parce que michel elle
a côtoyé d'autres patientes et patients
qui attendait depuis parfois 46 eur il y
avait 90 patients qui étaient en attente
y avait treize lits quinze mille en
france depuis le 1er janvier mais
comment peut-on se résoudre à ça
cette situation elle se reproduit
partout sur votre sur notre territoire
donc voilà votre rapport il a le mérite
de traiter une question centrale c'est
le sujet des urgences mais on sait bien
qu'il ya le goulet d'étranglement de
laval et que faute de bras le plus
souvent en faute de lits faute de
salaires attractifs aux deux moyens
faute de considération on est dans cette
crise il ya donc deux questions la
première c'est la question de la
permanence des soins sur ce point votre
rapport est quasi muet passé minuit il
n'y a plus de médecin de garde dans 29
départements en france monsieur le
ministre pourquoi ne pas vous être
prononcée pour le retour de l'obligation
de la permanence des soins première
question deuxième question monsieur le
ministre l'absurdité du forfait patients
urgence 19 euros de facturations pour
toute hospitalisation de notre faim tout
accès aux urgences non suivies d'une
hospitalisation
une politique inégalitaire irresponsable
monsieur le ministre comptez-vous mettre
fin aux fps pour éviter la rupture de
l'accès aux soins qui doit être notre
premier objectif merci à monsieur le
député monsieur frédéric valletoux pour
le groupe horizon et apparentés
goodell
allez-y oui monsieur le ministre la
présidente
l'accès aux soins est la question
centrale qui posait aussi aujourd'hui à
notre système de santé de manière large
et pas simplement à l'hôpital l'hôpital
est un grand corps malade mais le
système de santé libéral ne se porte pas
mieux un des facteurs qui affectent
l'ensemble du système de santé c'est la
question de la démographie médicale et
la pénurie de soignants dans un système
qui aujourd'hui en tout cas pour
l'hôpital accueille 21 millions de
personnes donc je sortirai des cas
particulier parce que sur un thème
millions personnes on peut trouver des
choses qui ne fonctionnent pas mais
globalement
c'est l' approche générale qui était
d'ailleurs celle de votre rapport qui
doit retenir notre notre attention
l'objectif est vous l'avez évoqué à deux
reprises dans votre intervention c'est
l'organisation de la conférence des
parties prenantes comme un point de
départ si j'ai bien compris à la remise
en place de ce système de ce nouveau
modèle que vous avez évoquées dans votre
intervention éliminèrent est
effectivement nouveaux boat l on en a on
en a besoin et tout cela a été déjà
longuement documenté comment va
s'organiser cette conférence des parties
prenantes quelle est la feuille de route
que vous allez donner à vos acteurs de
cette conférence des parties prenantes
est ce que cette conférence des parties
prenantes ne sera pas hospital au centre
et parce que le mal de l'hôpital ne
vient pas que de l'hôpital et des quatre
murs de l'hôpital mais c'est l'ensemble
du système de santé qui pèse sur les
dysfonctionnements que vit aujourd'hui
que j'ai eu des hospitaliers quelles
sont les priorités que vous allez donner
et surtout et surtout dans quel
calendrier allez-vous organiser tout
cela une des réussites du ségur de la
santé c'était pas la seule mais une des
réussites du secteur de la santé c'était
d'avoir cadres et les discussions entre
toutes les parties prenantes pour le
coup dans un temps limité et avec
quasiment une obligation d'essayer
trouver des points de consensus dans les
quelques semaines qui était de donner
aux uns et aux autres
je plaide pour effectivement à ce qu'on
aurait serré est-ce que c'est aussi
votre intention c'est pour nous
important et puis quelle est
l'articulation avec les calendriers du
plfss d'une part et la convention
médicale puisque la cnam et des
syndicats de médecins démarrer des
discussions importantes pour l'avenir du
système de santé
merci bien monsieur le député la parole
est à madame marie charlotte garat pour
le groupe écologiste
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je j'en profite de cette
intervention pour vous dire que je suis
ravi que vous évoquez la question de la
prévention j'espère que ça inclura la
question de la santé environnementale et
notamment des zoonoses et que ça fera
donc le lien avec l'impérieuse nécessité
de préserver nos écosystèmes
pour en revenir à la question des
urgences de la pénurie de généralistes
jusqu'aux urgences le système de soins à
l'hôpital et au bord de la noyade
l'audition d'aujourd'hui portent sur ce
sujet et bien évidemment à lyon ne fait
pas exception suite avec des discussions
avec le personnel et les syndicats je me
permets de donner quelques chiffres pour
alimenter nos échanges la situation au
fcl de lyon elle reste tendue dans un
contexte de lits d'aval restreinte par
rapport à 2021 un nombre de passages en
hausse de 5% par rapport à la période
pré co vide et un temps d'attentes
supérieure à 6 heures avec une hausse
notamment de 36 minutes par rapport à
2020 et un taux d'hospitalisation qui
reste très élevé je pense que tous les
collègues ici partageront constat de
l'état catastrophique de notre système
de soins que ce soit en ville ou dans
les zones plus rurales et la question
c'est finalement quelle solution vous
proposer on est là pour vous interroger
en tant que nouveau ministre de la santé
mais vu le bilan du dernier mandat il
est difficile de s'engager dans ses
discussions avec un espoir on va dire
francs et motivés sachant que votre
majorité a contribué activement à la
mise en difficulté de ce service public
allant même jusqu à continuer de fermer
des lits en pleine pandémie vous nous
parler des recommandations qui ont été
faites pour l'été vous nous parler d'un
plan d'urgence pour passer l'été mais
visiblement ça ne passe pas puisque la
semaine dernière encore un enfant en
détresse respiratoire n'a pas pu passer
les portes d'un service d'urgences aux
sables d'olonne littéralement les
parents et leurs enfants sont restés
bloqués devant un sas fermé ils ont
ensuite été envoyées vers le samu puis
les pompiers qui les ont aussi renvoyés
vers le samu enfin c'était un jeu ou la
balle se passer d'un acteur à l'autre et
la question c'est qu'est ce que vous
préconisez puisque à bordeaux par
exemple un modèle de régulation dax
urgence le 15 est en sous-effectif et
menace de craquer
finalement une fois le constat de la
situation catastrophique
quelle réaction pour y répondre je vous
remercie merci bien madame la députée la
parole est à monsieur pierre dharréville
pour la gauche démocrate et républicaine
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous vivons en mode dégradé et
depuis longtemps et la feuille de route
que vous êtes vous même concocté vient
en prendre acte et instituer ce mode
dégradé comme une solution les
urgentistes que je rencontre qui font
des miracles chaque jour nous voilà rien
de miraculeux si vous avez déjà beaucoup
conseiller emmanuel macron à ce qu'on
dit il faut reconnaître que ce n'est pas
votre action de ministre qui a fabriqué
cette situation c'est le choix répétés
de compresser les dépenses de santé de
supprimer des lits à l'hôpital public de
refuser de former les médecins dont nous
avons besoin de ne pas embaucher comme
il le faudrait et c'est des politiques
libérales en fait il ne faut pas se
contenter de traiter les symptômes il
faut traiter la cause et vous n'en
prenez pas le chemin il n'y a pas de
solution dans cette direction alors
qu'il eût fallu d impulsion forte vous
avez pris des mesures est libéral pour
l'été qui prennent acte de la pénurie de
fermetures de services au nom de la
mutualisation et qui plutôt que des
mesures pour les urgences directement se
contente de jouer sur la régulation
c'est à dire de limiter l'accès vous
envoyer aux personnels hospitaliers des
contres signaux décourageants quel est
le bilan à ce stade vous aurez sans
doute des statistiques taillé sur mesure
pour essayer de montrer les bienfaits de
cette politique mais dans les services
d'urgences ça ne passe pas car pendant
que la puissance publique demeure timide
face aux déserts médicaux les soignants
et les lits manquent toujours autant
l'hôpital ne vous ne ferez pas
disparaître les patients ils sont dans
les couloirs ils attendent des heures
durant et le personnel hospitalier n'en
peut plus de devoir détourner le regard
quand ils les traverses parce qu'il ne
peut pas faire autrement votre boîte à
outils manque de beaucoup de choses et
manque d'abord évidemment de lit et elle
a besoin d'ouvrières et d'ouvriers
prévoyez-vous véritablement comme vous
l'avait annoncé de mettre fin à tout à
toutes vos mesures de renoncement
prévaut que prévoyez vous pour donner
véritablement les moyens aux urgences de
faire face et maintenant pour la suite
quel est votre plan
merci bien monsieur le député la parole
est à monsieur paul andré colombani pour
le groupe liberté indépendant autres
maires et territoires merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues dès les premières lignes
de votre rapport vous souligner l'impact
sur le fonctionnement du système
hospitalier des pénuries de personnels
médicaux et non médicaux au sein de
l'hôpital conséquence indirecte de la
pandémie koffi 19 cette pénurie alimente
la question de la réintégration des
personnels soignants non vaccinés j'ai
voté pour l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants à l'époque où l'on pensé que
le vaccin éviter la contagion pour
autant il serait temps de faire preuve
d' apaisement et de pragmatisme tout
d'abord pourquoi pas dans les
territoires d'outre-mer où la rt1
réintégration des soignants d'en
vacciner dans les hôpitaux est un sujet
de grande tension
si votre rapport souligne à juste titre
le besoin de coopération entre la
médecine hospitalière et la médecine de
ville il s'en dégage une vision encore
trop hospital au centre est rappelons
qu'au nom de cette vision nous avions
étions allés jusqu à débattre sous la
précédente mandature du forfait de
réorientation des urgences qui revenait
à payer pour ne pas soigner en quelque
sorte
pour rompre en quelques semaines avec
cette logique il faudrait opérer un
véritable changement de paradigme
pourtant vos recommandations manque de
mesures incitatives envers la médecine
de ville déjà largement débordé qui fera
qui devra demain décharger les services
d'urgence une partie de leur activité
sans réelle compensation
l'attribution d'un supplément limité à
15 euros par acte médical régulier et le
plafonnement d'utilisation de
télémédecine sur l'activité totale
semble insuffisant et peu opérant êtes
vous prêt à prendre des mesures plus
incitatif au mieux associé la médecine
libérale
enfin je suis d'accord avec vous lorsque
vous dites que la place des chu comme
recours spécialisées régionales doit
être renforcée ainsi que les échanges
transfrontaliers dans les zones
concernées
la corse est je le rappelle la seule
région ne pas posséder de chu parmi les
nombreuses raisons qui justifieraient
son ouverture se trouve l'enjeu de la
gestion budgétaire et du bon
fonctionnement de nos services d'urgence
celui l'hôpital d'ajaccio par exemple
qui est contraint d'employer le très
nombreux intérimaires ce qui
particulièrement coûteux pour un
territoire périphériques en plus de
renforcer les moyens hospitaliers dont
nous manquons cruellement la
constitution d'un chu pour s inscrire
dans une projection aux méditerranéennes
en relation d'une voisine comme vous le
préconisez est débout donc favorable à
l'ouverture de discussions sur
l'ouverture d'un chu en corse merci bien
monsieur le député et bien je vais
passer la parole à monsieur le ministre
pour donc des éléments de réponse à
cette première salve de questions sont
nombreuses
merci la présidente mesdames messieurs
je vais essayer de reprendre les
questions à peu près dans l'ordre si
jamais j'ai oublié une réponse je pense
que vous n'hésiterez pas à me le
rappeler jeu pour y revenir parce que
j'avoue avoir pris des notes au fur et à
mesure et je suis un peu loin de la fac
où je prenais des notes très très vite
donc on ça devrait quand même ça devrait
quand même madame la rapporteure vous
parlez de fluidifier des sorties de la
problématique de l'aval des services
d'urgence c'est effectivement une
problématique qui n'est pas nouvelle
thomas baigner ici présent l'avaient
largement relevé dans le cadre du
travaux sur le pack de refondation des
urgences et les syndicats professionnels
le relève depuis depuis des années c'est
effectivement un des deux problèmes
majeurs des services d'urgence lamont en
étain laval en est un autre comme je le
disais tout à l'heure les urgences ont à
l'interface entre les difficultés de la
ville et les difficultés de l'hôpital
dans le cadre de laval le parcours des
personnages est vraiment essentiel quand
on sait les la morbi-mortalité qui
augmente chez les personnes âgées
lorsqu'ils passent des heures dans les
services d'urgences ou ne serait-ce que
quand ils arrivent dans un service
d'urgence qui est saturé c'est pour ça
que entre autres dans les différentes
mesures et déjà dans le pack de
refondation des urgences avant la crise
qu vides il y avait la volonté de
favoriser les entrées directes des
personnes âgées de mettre en place des
systèmes pré hospitaliers là aussi par
des équipes mobiles pour les prendre en
charge nous avons continué dans cette
logique en insistant sur les entrées
directes des personnes âgées en
favorisant dans le cas de la régulation
médicale je reviendrai surtout l'intérêt
de la régulation médicale
l'intégration de filière gériatrique
spécialisé j'ai été voir la semaine
dernière à saint-etienne le samu qui se
transforme en saas et qui a mis des
gériatres en régulation justement pour
anticiper ces parcours de soins il ya
également l'exemple de poitiers qui a
associé au sein de sa régulation du saas
le dac pour justement ces filières
difficile et ça fonctionne et ça permet
de mieux orienter les personnes âgées
sans les faire passer dans les urgences
lorsque cela est inutile en ce qui
concerne la prévention de la perte
d'autonomie et on parle de prévention
même si l'autonomie concerne
principalement mon collègue
jean-christophe combelles prévenir la
perte d'autonomie est là aussi essentiel
dans le cadre des consultations
systématique que nous commençons à part
mettre en oeuvre mais on a travaillé la
forme il ya ces consultations qui vont
anticiper la perte d'autonomie à 65 ans
75 ans pour justement là aussi anticiper
les parcours de santé globaux de ses
patients et prévenir également dans le
cadre qui est de ce qui a été fait par
le gouvernement avant mais mesure il ya
la possibilité pour les services
d'hospitalisation à domicile de faire
des dossiers
précoce en avance pour les personnes qui
sont dans les ehpad pour ce que lorsque
il y a un problème de santé aiguë on
puisse les admettre tout de suite en
achat d vous le savez comme moi c'est
toujours très difficile l'achat des ça
nécessite des délais qui ne sont pas
compatibles avec les urgences là on a un
outil et ça marche bien pour anticiper
tout cela donc là la fluidification de
laval j'aurais sûrement l'occasion d'y
revenir et quelque chose d'essentiel
parlé de bide management qui reviendrait
tout à l'heure et parmi l'ensemble de
ces mesures la prise en charge des plus
âgés est effectivement quelque chose qui
doit nous nous alerter
monsieur certains par dont vous parliez
de plusieurs points et vont venir sur la
notion de partenariat public privé sur
le partenariat public privé je crois que
les éléments de la boîte à outils sont
claires la pénibilité qu'elle soit de la
nuit qu'ils soient du week-end ne peut
pas ne doit plus reporter uniquement sur
le public et les structures privées des
structures d'urgence privés doivent
apporter leur pierre à ce dispositif et
doivent y participer a fortiori et c'est
ce qui est mis dans les mesures d'été
lorsqu'ils décident souvent de façon
unilatérale d'ailleurs de fermer la nuit
parce qu'ils manquent de personnel mais
il faut que leur personnel et nous avons
rendu ça possible puissent aller
renforcer le service d'urgence publique
de proximité de toute façon
on ne sortira pas et c'est un peu ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure de cette
problématique s'il n'y a pas un travail
qui devient collaboratif et non plus un
travail concurrentiel c'est tout l'état
d'esprit de passer de ce système de
l'offre un système de réponse aux
besoins saivet toute la base des travaux
de la conférence des parties prenantes
j'y reviendrai sur la notion de la
pénibilité vous avez vous avez pu
constater que c'est la première fois
qu'un texte reconnaît la notion de
pénibilité du travail à l'hôpital en
particulier de la pénibilité du travail
de nuit donc je pense que c'est une
ouverture de la porte pour travailler
justement dans cette conférence des
parties prenantes sur la reconnaissance
de la pénibilité
monsieur cateau vous nous avez parlé de
fermetures de lits oui bien sûr il ya
des fermetures de lits mais il ya il ya
beaucoup de raisons pour les fermetures
de lits déjà voir le système de santé et
le système de réponse à
l'hospitalisation uniquement par le
prisme du mca c'est à dire de médecine
chirurgie esthétique et se tromper sur
le fonctionnement actuel de notre
système de santé cm de santé il
fonctionne de plus en plus avec ce
fameux virage ambulatoire sur des
hospitalisations qui sont plus courtes
des hospitalisations de jour dont on se
sert beaucoup en chirurgie dont on se
sert beaucoup dans les pathologies
cancéreuses et parallèlement le nombre
de lits d'hospitalisation de jour a
augmenté mais encore plus loin et là on
parle toujours du virage domiciliaire
les hospitalisations à domicile elle qui
est une volonté de nos concitoyens de ne
plus être systématiquement à l'hôpital
on me dit ont bondi de 10% en ce qui
concerne le nombre de places est de 15%
au nombre d'activités alors oui on
constate dans les services d'urgences
qu'on manque de lits d'aval on manque
aussi de lits d'aval parce qu'on manque
de personnel parce que des gens quitter
l'hôpital ils ont quitté l'hôpital après
la crise qu vite pour de multiples
raisons sur lesquelles on pourrait
revenir on manque aussi de lits d'aval
parce qu'il ya un mauvais équilibre
entre l'activité programmée et
l'activité non programmé ça ça doit être
quelque chose qui revient dans nos
discussions et sur lequel il va falloir
se pencher la réponse aux besoins c'est
un équilibre délicat subtil entre
l'activité programmée à l'activité non
programmés et c'est cet équilibre qu'il
faut retrouver
vous parlez d'un
bicéphale et à la tête de l'hôpital avec
un soignant un médecin et un
administratif on dit un médecin je peux
presque tendance à dire un soignant
pourquoi forcément un médecin on peut se
poser la question et un administratif
faut savoir que déjà dans le cadre du
rapport du professeur clarisse il ya un
certain nombre de mesures qui a été
proposé et nous allons déjà allé
jusqu'au bout de ces mesures pour les
évaluer avant de savoir s'ils sont
suffisantes ou pas en tout cas moi c'est
ce que je veux faire sur l'ensemble des
mesures que je mettrai en place c'est
aller jusqu'au bout les évaluer les
garder s'ils sont efficaces et je
voulais dit ne pas les garder si elles
sont pas efficaces pour ceux de
gouvernance hospitalière allons jusqu'au
bout
la suppression des 1eres on pourrait en
discuter je crois que c'est pas une
bonne idée mais je sais pas si nous
devons en débattre ici en tout cas dans
la la conférence des parties prenantes
dans cette rénovation du système de
santé je crois que l'état doit prendre
sa place
régaliennes indispensable mais aussi les
élus mais aussi les soigner mais aussi
les soignants et les ars sont quand même
une représentation de l'état à l'échelle
des territoires car dans cette
conférence et j'en parlerai après je
veux surtout m'appuyer sur les
territoires et revenir sur cette
organisation territoriale parce que
c'est au niveau des territoires qu'on
trouve les solutions c'est au niveau des
territoires qu'on réunit les
professionnels pour avancer
madame fiat
vous parlez en juillet 2019 des services
d'urgence en grève que de souvenirs pour
moi puisque j'étais à la tête des
mouvements de grève justement donc ne
vous inquiétez pas je connais la
problématique des services d'urgence
depuis longtemps vous parlez 2019 je
vous rappelle que c'est en 2013 je
parlais tout à l'heure du no b challenge
que nous avons mis en place de nos bêtes
challenge déjà pour alerter sur ces
problématiques de services d'urgence
donc ne vous inquiétez pas rien n'a
changé et je suis toujours médecins
hospitaliers et toujours médecin
urgentiste dans l'âme et dans le coeur
même si actuellement j'ai un boulot de
ministre mais qui durera le temps qu'il
durera donc j'ai toujours mon expérience
du
du terrain c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire peu de service sont fermées d'après
les retours que j'ai sont totalement
fermé il ya des services qui ont
organisé la régulation d'aval il y à une
vingtaine de services qui ont fermé dans
des territoires réellement réellement
dont des services privés d'ailleurs dans
les territoires où il est un autre
service à proximité qui a d'ailleurs eu
à supporter cette décharge au niveau de
la nuit même problématique il y à un les
patients sont accueillis par un
professionnel de santé et réorienter en
tout cas c'est moi les informations j'ai
si vous avez des endroits précis où il
ya des fermetures de ce type je serais
ravi de prendre ces informations dit que
les urgences ou fruits les jours j'en
souffre mais pas que les urgences et je
disais tout à l'heure voire la crise
systémique de notre système santé que
par le prisme des urgences ne permet pas
de voir l'ensemble c'est traiter un
symptôme sait pas traiter l'ensemble de
la maladie dire qu' il ne faut pas se
rendre aux services d'urgence c'est faux
sait jamais ce que nous avons dit nous
avons dit que les patients seront
toujours pris en charge et gelé noté
clairement dans le rapport comme j'ai
noté que le parcours de soins le
meilleur n'était sûrement pas
systématiquement de passer aux urgences
quand on a mal aux genoux depuis trois
semaines quand on a un bouton quand on a
mal à la gorge le meilleur parcours de
soins c'est pas aller aux urgences mais
moyenne au milieu de la nuit on y attend
on n'est pas forcément bien pris en
charge et c'est un urgentiste qui vous
le dis parce que les pathologies qui
relèvent de la médecine générale sont
mieux pris en charge par un médecin
généraliste donc l'idée c'est
essentiellement de comptes de construire
les meilleurs parcours de soins pour les
patients vous savez en urgence on parle
de qualifier agir orienté c'est la base
de notre métier qualifié ces définir le
besoin de soins derrière la demande et
c'est le job des urgentistes et de la
régulation médicale agir bien sûr pour
préserver la ville et la fonction et
orienter le patient dans le meilleur
parcours de soins
monsieur juin chers confrères
vous parler de la qualité de l'accueil
du no b challenge je vous remercie de
remettre remettre ce nobel challenge un
petit peu au goût du jour il date de
2013 comme je viens de le dire il a
permis quand même une prise de
conscience qu'il faut sûrement réactive
et sur les difficultés de l'aval des
services d'urgence
ces difficultés de la balle j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en parler et je ne sais
plus qui m'a posé la question sur le b
de management en fait le bnd management
s'est passé vous je crois madame siècle
c'est absolument pas quelque chose de
libéral ou de quoi que ce soit c'est
simplement mieux gérer les
disponibilités de lits à l'hôpital c'est
pouvoir s'arranger que contient ni
disponibles on puisse y mettre
impatience et pouvoir aussi assurer la
sortie des patients lorsqu'ils n'ont
plus besoin d'être dans un lit c'est une
organisation si une organisation qui
fonctionne les hôpitaux qu'ils ont mises
en place sont tout à fait satisfait de
ce mode de fonctionnement ça oblige un
peu de changer les habitudes de mes
confrères je le dis sans ambages c'est
pas toujours simple mais en tout cas
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne sur
le nombre de médecins il vous aura pas
échappé mon cher confrère que le
gouvernement a enfin supprimé le numerus
clausus malheureusement la gestion
depuis des décennies de ce nombre de
médecins fait que en gros 15 ans pour
former un médecin donc les effets ne
seront pas immédiats
mais vous relèverez aussi que dans le
cadre des mesures d'été personne n'en a
parlé ici il est une mesure spécifique
pour les praticiens à diplôme hors union
européenne pour leurs possibilités pour
leur laisser la possibilité à ses
collègues qui travaillent déjà à côté de
nous qui sont très bons pour la plupart
et j'en ai eu plusieurs dents mon
service de pouvoir continuer à
travailler chez nous ce qui est
nécessaire
30% des ide qui partent dans les cinq
premières années moi j'avais surtout le
chiffre de 20% ide qui quittent les
études donc je pense que c'est intégré
de dans la question de l'arrêt des
études pour les infirmières est quelque
chose qui me préoccupe beaucoup parce
que si du jour au lendemain nous
arrivions à régler ce problème et bien
c'est 20% d'infirmières en plus tous les
ans qui arriverait sur le marché du
travail alors pourquoi qui tels
les études quand on discute avec les et
représentants de ces infirmières et avec
des élèves infirmières ce que j'ai fait
ce que je continue à faire il ya deux
raisons principales la première c'est la
paupérisation avec des difficultés sur
les versements des bourses qui sont
l'apanage de région vous le savez les
difficultés aussi concernant
les stages les indemnisations les
trajets l'absence de logement qu'on va
retrouver aussi pour les professionnels
médicaux et les internes et les externes
donc ça je compte m'y atteler et puis
aussi parce que les études ne
correspondent plus à ce que les
infirmières trouve quand elles arrivent
à l'hôpital elle parle de maltraitance
est en fait cette maltraitance quand on
discute avec elle c'est une inadéquation
entre le contenu des études et la
réalité du travail sur le terrain et je
compte entreprendre rapidement un
travail sur avec ma collègue sylvie
retailleau sur l'université risation ou
du beaucoup ce terme d'une façon
générale des professions de santé mais
surtout sur la rénovation des formations
et en particulier de la formation
infirmière
la qualité de vie oui la qualité de vie
je ne dis pas qu'elles étaient dues au
travail concernant les soignants parce
que d'expérience j'ai vu quand les mes
collègues infirmiers aides soignants
médecins sont pas bien au boulot ils
sont pas bien chez eux et c'est souvent
pour ça qu'ils partent donc cette
qualité de vie est essentiel c'est un
enjeu majeur pour redonner du sens du
sens à nos à nos métiers et la
reconnaissance de la pénibilité j'ai dit
je le redis est pour moi un enjeu là
aussi majeur c'est ce qu'on a commencé à
faire avec le travail de nuit il faudra
probablement aller plus loin mais
j'espère sur la conférence des parties
prenantes pour nous soulever des sujets
principaux
concernant le plan variole je vous
rassure il existe toujours il est
toujours opérationnel tant d'hommes de
doses quand plan de vaccination de toute
la population française en deux semaines
mais cela impose tout autre arrêt
d'activité pendant deux semaines voilà
c'est à dire que si effectivement nous
avions une attaque chimique chimiques
biologiques bardon à la variole et bien
le pays s'arrêterait pour vacciner en
quinze jours toute la population pour
nous mettre à l'abri de la variole qui
est hautement plus dangereuse que le
monde qui évoque ce dont on parle
aujourd'hui
monsieur isaac sibille m'avait parlé de
recours inapproprié aux services
d'urgence comme quoi je disais que
c'était la principale cause des
difficultés
c'est surtout la plus importante en
nombre déjà c'est à dire que toutes les
études font état de 30 à 40 % de
patients se présentant aux urgences qui
pourraient être pris en charge autrement
une immense partie à peu près les trois
quarts par la médecine de ville et un
car qui pourrait avoir des entrées
directes dans les services bien sûr ce
n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga c'est une
partie du problème mais si demain on
diminue de 40% la fréquentation des
services d'urgence croyez moi ça va
faire du bien aux urgentistes et ça fera
du bien aux patients donc déjà il faut
il faut partir il faut partir là dessus
les gens m'ont vers les services
d'urgence parce que les horaires sont
plus larges parce que les examens
complémentaires sont plus possibles etc
oui mais ils attendent des heures et
c'est souvent je les dis pas la
meilleure prise en charge qui peut être
parfois bien meilleur fait par un
médecin généraliste alors les structures
intermédiaires vous aviez effectivement
avec jean yves grall proposer un type de
structure
très séduisant je dois le dire ces
structures intermédiaires mais qui
malheureusement alors est-ce que c'est
l'effet post crise a été complètement
détourné aujourd'hui il a été compté
détournés par des ce qu'on appelle des
centres de soins immédiats et non
programmés qui sont des structures la
plupart du temps privé qui ne
travaillent qu'en journée qui ne
participe ni à la pénibilité de la nuit
ni à la pénibilité du week end et qui
d'après mes collègues généralistes ont
une
utilité pour laquelle on peut être
partagé ils ont une utilité de réponse
immédiate un besoin mais malheureusement
on trouve beaucoup de nos concitoyens
qui pour des pathologies chroniques ne
vont plus être pris en charge et vont
préférer ce type de structure un petit
peu immédiate et n'auront que des
épisodes aigus qui vont être pris en
charge et pas du tout la pathologie
chronique bref il y as besoin très
certainement d'une évaluation de ces
structures alors elles répondent à un
besoin qui est non couverts aujourd'hui
mais attention de ne pas en faire la
panacée par contre des médecins
généralistes et j'ai pu encore le voir
la semaine dernière à valenciennes ont
mis en place des structures extrêmement
original avec les libéraux d'un secteur
qui ouvre en journée la maison médicale
de garde qui prennent en charge des
patients qui leur sont adressées par la
régulation médicale ou par les services
d'urgence ça donne entièrement
satisfaction il y a plein d'endroits où
ça se met en place j'ai vu à côté de
dison h9 ça fonctionne aussi bref nous
avons des solutions qui émerge du
terrain et c'est ça que je vais aller
chercher je veux aller voir pourquoi
valenciennes ça marche et pourquoi on va
me dire que ça marche pas à nantes art
nous ou à carcassonne donc c'est ça en
tout cas l'esprit que je veux conduire
dans le cadre de cette conférence des
parties prenantes
monsieur de la porte vous m'avez parlé
d'un rapport technique et désincarnée je
suis absolument désolé je n'accepte pas
ce mot c'est certes un rapport technique
mais considéré que j'ai une prise en
charge désincarné des patients que je
soigne encore un mois au mieux c'est une
méconnaissance de mon parcours au pire
c'est être particulièrement déplaisants
canton d'omont exercice professionnel
ou avait parlé
[Applaudissements]
écoutez je suis désolé mais en tout cas
on va reparler du rapport que j'ai écris
donc gelé plus poursuivre et monsieur le
ministre s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues alors après minuit il n'y a
plus de permanence dans ce rebond dans
beaucoup de territoires oui il y en à 98
% sur tout le territoire national avant
minuit il faut aussi rappeler les trains
qui arrivent à l'heure et ce qui me
préoccupe dans ses 98 % sur les 2 % qui
n'ont pas cette permanence de soins en
soirée et le week-end est sûre c'est sur
ces 2 % que je veux m'appuyer
quant à la permanence des soins après
minuit j'espère que vous me donnerez
quitus quant à mon expérience là dessus
qui date maintenant d'une quarantaine
d'années sur les urgences et la
régulation médicale les prises en charge
après minuit sont soit du conseil
médical soin des patients qui doivent
être prises en charge par des urgences
il y as extrêmement peu d'actes après
minuit qui nécessite simplement une
consultation il y à des problématiques
je ne met pas de côté en particules à
pratiquer des certificats de décès
j'aimerais que tous on se penche aussi
sur cette problématique
mais la prise en charge des patients
croyez moi c'est soit du conseil soit du
transfert dans le service des urgences
l'obligation de la permanence des soins
tout va dépendre de quoi on parle avoir
une obligation à l'échelle d'un
territoire pour assurer le besoin de
santé de nos concitoyens le soir et le
week-end oui et je vous suis vrai là
dedans mais je parle bien d'obligations
collective je ne crois pas aux
obligations individuelles ça ne
fonctionne pas mais par contre mettre
les acteurs du territoire face à leurs
responsabilités pour assurer cette
réponse aux besoins c'est quelque chose
que je compte je compte conduire alors
le forfait patients aux urgences ça
c'est très intéressant parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler sur justement
cette rénovation du financement des
structures d'urgence que je considère
comme exemplaires exemplaires pourquoi
parce que ce n'est plus un financement à
l'activité uniquement c'est d'abord un
financement populationnelle qui
répondent donc aux besoins de santé de
nos concitoyens
c'est une part de financement à
l'activité et c'est une part qui va
croître de financement à la qualité à
l'efficience je pense que c'est par ce
biais là qu'on va améliorer les choses
alors maintenant le forfait patients
urgence de 19 euros est largement
inférieur à ce que payent déjà nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui pour la plupart
d'entre eux déjà il est pris en charge
par l'assurance maladie pour une grande
partie de nos concitoyens et les
personnes les plus fragiles en plus ceux
qui ont la chance d'avoir une mutuelle
s'est largement pris en charge mais je
le répète de nombreux patients paye déjà
ce ticket modérateur qu'on appelait
avant pour les services d'urgence il ne
le voit pas parce que ça passe de façon
extrêmement transparents mais il le paye
et croyez-moi quand vous arrivez que
vous avez une consultation une prise de
sang un scanner plus une cassure
rotation de spécialistes le ticket
modérateur il est plus près de 150 euros
que 19 euros donc moi je considère et
tous les gens avec lesquels j'ai
travaillé là dessus que ce forfait
patients aux urgences et au contraire un
élément d'équité pour que tout le monde
puisse être pris en charge de façon
correcte
le cheval tout le la conférence des
parties prenantes alors déjà sur la
conférence des parties prenantes elle va
elle va s'intégrer dans le cadre du
conseil national de la refondation dont
ça va être un des éléments ce qui semble
tout à fait logique et donc qui va être
officiellement annoncée par président de
la république début septembre pour
autant nous n'avons pas attendu et vous
le savez pour travailler sur cette
conférence des parties prenantes alors
cette conférence des parties prenantes
avant de vous déclinez les principaux
axes elle va reposer sur deux piliers
qui sont pour moi essentiel le premier
c'est qu'on parle bien de santé globale
et quand on parle de santé c'est la
prévention le dépistage le soin et de
suivi le deuxième un des éléments et
c'est ressorti de beaucoup de vos
questions c'est la perte de sens pour
les professionnels de santé aujourd'hui
sur leur métier et je compte m l'éthique
au centre de tous nos travaux dans la
conférence des parties prenantes
pourquoi parce que l'éthique c'est
répondre à ce pourquoi nous sommes là
c'est quoi être soignants en 2022 c'est
quoi être soignants en 2025 c'est quoi
être soignants en 2035 c'est à ces
questions qui va falloir répondre par
les différentes points de la partie de
la conférence alors cette conférence
nous sommes actuellement dans une phase
de préparation avec des discussions en
bilatéral je suis d'ailleurs le plaisir
de discuter avec vous en tant que
président de la fhf toute cette phase de
préparation va se continuer pendant le
mois d'août elle nous permet de faire
émerger les sujets principaux et là
aussi ces sujets seront en
transversalité il est hors de question
dans la conférence de parties prenantes
d'avoir des sujets qui ne concernent
qu'une partie de la santé par exemple on
parlait tout à l'heure de l'hôpital de
la gouvernance de l'hôpital ce n'est pas
un sujet les parties prenantes parce
qu'il n'est pas transversale donc on
préférera que de sujets transversaux à
l'issue de cette phase de préparation et
de l'émergence des sujets principaux en
travaillant aussi sur les contributions
de tous le monde écrite depuis six mois
en gros depuis le début des campagnes
nous aurons une phase de concertation
d'interrogation extrêmement large de nos
citoyens qui se fera sous deux modes un
mode numérique et un mode type grand
débat au niveau des territoires je le
redis c'est au niveau des territoires
que nous allons travailler et c'est sur
cette concertation échelles de
territoire que je compte sur les élus
pour conduire ses discussions avec
systématiquement le triptyque et ça je
serai entre guillemets intraitable
soigner soignants et lui on ne peut plus
continuer à parler de notre système de
santé sans mettre les patients les
soigner là aussi autour de la table
cette phase d'interrogation va durer un
mois un mois et demi nous aurons ensuite
le retour de ces informations ce qui
nous permettra de définir ou de
continuer à remplir cette fameuse boîte
à outils parce que je veux rester sur ce
principe de boîte à outils une fois
cette boîte à outils définis nous
reviendrons vers les territoires en
disant voilà les outils voilà les
problèmes de santé votre territoire
voilà les outils est ce que les outils
vous convienne ou pas on vous a donné un
tournevis cruciforme voulait un
tournevis plat très bien on va changer
l'outil c'est comme ça que ça va se
passer par des montées descentes avec
les territoires et avec les parties
prenantes pour arriver dès mi de début
2023 à une boîte à outils finalisé
un programme qui va s'échelonner sur le
temps et à la mise en à la main des
professionnels du territoire des élus dé
soigner de ses outils pour répondre aux
besoins les ars ont parlé tout à l'heure
des ars je compte que les ars soit
aidantes pour la mise à disposition des
solutions qui sont trouvés sur le
territoire j'ai vu pendant mes
déplacements des solutions extrêmement
original mais qui ont aussi
l'originalité de sortir un peu du cadre
réglementaire eh bien mon principe n'est
pas de les faire rentrer dans le cadre
réglementaire mon principe est d'élargir
le cadre pour que quand quelque chose
fonctionne on puisse continuer à le
faire fonctionner
madame garin je crois oui santé
environnementale je vous rassure oui
bien sûr la santé environnementale est
complètement au centre de notre
réflexion on pousse le concept one elf
le terme anglais maintenant largement
utilisés sur ce problème de santé
globale et d'ailleurs vous le savez
l'évolution du conseil scientifique a
que nous mettons en place cette
évolution vers ce conseil de veille et
d'alerté pour les risques sanitaires est
dans une logique wanna love c'est marqué
dans le décret et sera associé avec
vétérinaire climatologues et c'est pour
que nous puissions être prêt sur
l'ensemble des risques sanitaires et
particulièrement ceux liés aux problèmes
environnementaux
mais parler de lyon lyon bordeaux naïade
oui il ya un service d'urgence qui a
fermé à lyon de mes souvenirs c'est un
service d'urgences privé et l'activité
est reporté sur les deux autres services
d'urgence dans le sud est il a fermé on
me confirme une journée ouvert ensuite
c'est souvent ça malheureusement des
fermetures un peu inopinés et si ces
fermetures ne sont pas anticipés comme
nous le demandons dans la boîte à outils
pour l'été eh bien ça peut entraîner des
difficultés si c'est un minimum
anticiper les autres services autour
peuvent peuvent y répondre à l'attenté
aux urgences est toujours quelque chose
que l'on met en avant je vais vous dire
peut-être un scoop c'est que aux
urgences quand c'est urgent n'attend pas
c'est tout le principe d urgence quand
vous arrivez avec un infarctus aux
urgences vous attendez pas parce que en
moyenne vous voyez dans les sept minutes
une infirmière d'accueil et
d'orientation et cette infirmière
d'accueil orientation qui est une
professionnelle
eric une formation spécifique va en
fonction de votre pathologie et de la
priorité qui lui est donnée vous faire
passer avant d'autres par contre si vous
arrivez avec un traumatisme de cheville
qui date de quatre semaines vous risquez
d'attendre très longtemps et c'est ça
que nous voulons éviter en orientant
différemment les patients del de l'amour
alors vous m'avez parlé d'un problème
aux sables d'olonne dont je n'ai pas eu
écho mais à lendemain à nantes je me
renseignerai sur ce problème si
effectivement un enfant en détresse a
attendu devant une porte fermée c'est
inacceptable et je vais aller voir
exactement ce qui s'est passé
monsieur dharréville vous avez parlé de
me dégradé comme solution je ne
considère pas que
réguler médicalement et correctement un
patient qui a une demande de soins soit
un mode dégradé je considère au
contraire que c'est un mode beaucoup
plus moderne et beaucoup plus approprié
à la pathologie des patients réguliers
n'est pas une dégradation par contre
tout envoyé aux urgences sans faire le
sans faire la part de ce qu'il doit y
aller ou de ce qui sera mal pris et pour
le coup pour moi un mode dégradé le mode
dégradé c'est de dire il n'y a plus rien
en ville il ya plus de réponses tout le
monde va aux urgences et puis quelque
part dieu et retrouvera les siens ce
serait à mon avis une très mauvaise
gestion
par une mesurette libéral alors je oui
je sais pas ce que c'est que les
mesurettes libéral j'avoue que ça ne
semble pas été très libéral quand
j'appuie et je m'appuie sur l'hôpital
public certes je met en avant aussi des
solutions pour nos collègues libéraux
parce que vouloir régler le problème de
l'hôpital et je lui ai déjà dit sans
vouloir travailler avec les médecins
libéraux c'est partie perdue d'annonce
donc oui il y avait un système je vous
connaissez sûrement qu'elle avenant
un article l'avenant 9 de la convention
médicale extrêmement compliqué pour que
nos collègues libéraux puissent est de
valoriser des patients qui prennent en
charge dans le cadre de la régulation
médicale ce sont eux qui nous ont fait
remarquer cette difficulté c'est pour ça
que nous avons changé cette mesure pour
une mesure plus simple plus facilement
applicables et qui des premiers chiffres
que j'ai qui ne sont pas des
statistiques taillé sur mesure montre
que c'est plutôt efficace
donner les moyens aux urgences oui mais
je le redis si on focalise que sur les
services d'urgence on va se tromper de
solutions on va donner un traitement
symptomatique sans traiter la maladie et
on n'ira pas bien loin
monsieur colombani vous m'avez parlé de
la réintégration des personnels non
vaccinés dès là dessus mon discours ne
change pas je suis désolé je m'appuie
sur les recommandations des
scientifiques à jour les recommandations
des scientifiques le déconseille si
jamais voir même le déconseille
fortement que ce soit le dernier avis du
conseil scientifique de l'académie de
médecine le conseil de l'ordre des
infirmiers et la haute autorité de santé
nous suivrons d'ailleurs dans le texte
de loi que vous avez contribué à faire
passer il ya la possibilité de saisir la
haute autorité de santé si la situation
change et pour revoir ce problème il ya
le problème strictement scientifique il
ya aussi là un problème éthique et je le
redis moi je rends hommage aux soignants
qui sont fait soigner parce que qu'ils
sont fait vacciner pardon parce que ce
sont eux qui est tenue la première ligne
et croyez moi j'en sais quelque chose
forfait de réorientation des urgences se
payer pour ne pas soigner non banon
forfait de réorientation des urgences
c'est simplement la législation
financière du temps qui est passé par
l'infirmière c'est un acte infirmier qui
a réorienté le patient pour l'éviter il
faut dire à nos patients avant de vous
déplacer appelé appelez votre médecin
traitant s'il n'est pas disponible
appeler le 15 ce qui leur permettra de
ne pas aller vers un service d'urgence
sont les réorientera ensuite ailleurs
pas de mesures incitatives pour la
médecine générale je croyais avoir
répondu en disant quand même que 15
euros de plus pour un acte fait sur la
régulation médicale c'est une mesure
incitative
le déplafonnement de la télémédecine le
déplafonnement de la télémédecine je
suis désolé c'est une mauvaise idée à
part donner beaucoup d'argent à des
entreprises qui se spécialise que dans
la télémédecine avec des médecins qui ne
font que ça aujourd'hui en france demain
probablement à l'étranger n'est pas une
bonne solution par contre les
contraintes qui sont mises à savoir
qu'un praticien ne peut pas avoir plus
d'un certain pourcentage 40 % d'activité
télémédecine me semble garant pour que
le praticien que vous ayez à l'autre
bout de l'ordinateur soit un praticien
réellement compétents et qu'ils prennent
en charge des patients le problématique
des chu est une problématique
large complexe concernant la corse je me
propose si vous souhaitez qu'on en
discute et je suis prêt à en discuter
avec vous quand vous voulez jamais
oublier que la problématique d'un chu ce
n'est ce n'est pas une
devenir ses astuces et pas une solution
miracle qui va permettre d'avoir des
professionnels de santé de venir chu ça
impose d'avoir de l'enseignement d'avoir
un niveau de recherche d'avoir des
unités inserm c'est ça les tickets de
chu croire que le il suffit pour amener
plein de professionnels est une erreur
mais par contre je ne connais pas
spécialement le dossier de la demande du
chu en corse mais je suis prêt comme je
les dis à me pencher avec vos petites
petites solutions pour laquelle moi je
crois beaucoup c'est la création de
postes territoriaux de postes
universitaires territoriaux et vous en
êtes mesdames et messieurs les députés
un élément essentiel c'est à dire la
création sur des fonds certes
territoriaux de postes universitaires
qui sont ensuite payé à moitié par
l'hôpital et qui permettent dès lors que
des candidats répondent aux exigences
universitaires il faut quand même pas
sortir de ce tas de créer très
facilement des postes a été fait déjà
dans plusieurs endroits en france ça
peut continuer à être fait c'est
probablement une première étape
intéressante pour les structures qui
souhaiteraient devenir universitaire
voilà j'espère avoir répondu à toutes
les questions presse sinon je suis prêt
à une deuxième salve peut-être très
grosse salve monsieur le ministre en
tout cas merci merci pour vos réponses
claires et précises et donc
effectivement mes chers collègues nous
avons
27 28 questions 27 questions donc il va
falloir être concis éviter la paraphrase
la redondance et de toute façon je suis
certaine que vous allez être vraiment
très synthétique afin de permettre aux
ministres de répondre monsieur le
ministre que je vous propose comme mes
collègues vont être très con si c'est de
les prendre vraiment tout et que vous
puissiez faire est que vous puissiez
faire une réponse une synthèse voilà
bon par rapport à toutes les questions
sinon en tous les cas sachez il vaut il
faut être vraiment qu'on s'y parce que
je vois les choses arriver certains vous
poser les questions et ensuite vont
partir et on va se retrouver avec trois
personnes dans la salle et ça ne se fait
pas donc je le dis clairement c'est à
dire que vous posez vos questions et
vous écoutez aussi des réponses du
ministre ça me semble quand même très
clair très bien ok vous êtes d'accord
soyez concis alors voilà eh ben je vais
commencer avec marc ferracci pour la
première question qu'on 6 merci beaucoup
de minutes présidente monsieur le
ministre dans le rapport qui suivent
votre mission flash vous insisté sur la
nécessité de renforcer je cite la place
des chu comme recours spécialisées
régionales voir supra régionale ainsi
que sur le renforcement des échanges
transfrontaliers dans les zones
concernées c'est pourquoi ma question
porte sur la coopération bilatérale
franco suisse en matière de santé à
l'aune de l'accord cadre qui existent
sur la coopération sanitaire
transfrontalière alors je vais aller à
l'essentiel il ya quelques mois le
ministre des solidarités de la santé de
la république française monsieur olivier
ferrand et le conseiller fédéral en
charge du département fédéral de
l'intérieur de la confédération suisse
mme suire alain berset se sont engagés à
avancer sur trois sujets le premier
sujet c'est la mise en place d'une
commission mixte prévue par l'accord
cadre sur la coopération sanitaire
transfrontalière le deuxième sujet c'est
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et de recrutement des personnels de
santé afin d'assurer une stabilité du
personnel dans les établissements des
territoires concernés
le troisième sujet c'est la garantie
d'offre de soins de qualité pour les
patients français et suisses et services
de santé de part et d'autre de la
frontière sont confrontés au même défi
la crise du corridor a mis en lumière la
force des liens entre les équipes
hospitalières
est ce que vous pouvez monsieur le
ministre nous indiquer ce que sont les
avancées récentes sur ces trois sujets
merci merci bien
monsieur mathieu mathieu pardon marchio
oui oui monsieur le ministre je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur la situation
de très fortes tensions au sein d'un
grand nombre de services d'urgences
hospitalières ce problème touche une
majorité départements en france très
exactement 60 selon la liste dressée par
samu urgences france en mai en mai
dernier j'illustrerai mon propos avec ce
qu'il se passe depuis plusieurs mois au
centre hospitalier de douai 2 chi dans
ma circonscription du nord à partir de
juillet 2021 le fonctionnement des
urgences pédiatriques et la permanence
des soins de l'établissement grandement
été affecté par le départ de nombreux
pédiatres à la mi septembre faute de
personnel ce service a donc été purement
et simplement fermé la nuit de 18 heures
à 9 heures les week-ends ou les jours
fériés si ce service est de nouveau
ouverte 24 heures sur 24 c'est désormais
la ligne permanence des soins au service
d'accueil des urgences et la ligne ce
mur qui sont sous tension pour la
période estivale 2022 face aux rumeurs
persistantes qui laissait entrevoir une
fermeture complète au mois d'août j'ai
donc contacté la direction
d'établissement celle ci m'a informé que
les urgences resterait ouverte et que la
ligne smur seraient pourvus mais que les
tensions resterait très forte en raison
de lignes toujours vacante malgré les
efforts menés sur le recrutement de
praticiens ceci ne serait pas finalisé
et ne seraient finalisées qu'en octobre
2022 cette situation interroge quant à
la capacité de l'établissement à assurer
la permanence des soins dans de bonnes
conditions sur le court et moyen terme
monsieur le ministre tout en souhaitant
très sincèrement salué le travail
exceptionnel et le dévouement de
l'ensemble des personnels de santé je
vous appelle à agir face à cette
situation inacceptable
que comptez vous faire pour faire en
sorte que l'ensemble des lignes
d'urgence et smur soient pourvus à doué
deux shih mais également dans l'ensemble
du système hospitalier français jean
merci merci bien monsieur sébastien de
l'obuts
merci ma présidente monsieur le ministre
je me suis rendu dans plusieurs hôpitaux
de marseille et j'ai fait un appel à
témoignages sur les réseaux sociaux ça a
permis de recueillir directement la
parole des soignants ou bien des usagers
qui se rendent dans ces hôpitaux ce qui
en ressort est insupportable et
inadmissible malgré le dévouement des
soignants à toute épreuve leur travail
formidable est absolument indispensable
ce qui en ressort principalement c'est
le manque de moyens humains financiers
et matériels
les suppressions de lits les conditions
de travail insoutenables les urgences
qui ferment et de façon récurrente les
déserts médicaux le refus incompris de
ne pas réintégrer les soignants non
vaccinés alors qu'au manque de soignants
parmi les témoignages que j'ai reçus
voici trois questions simples et pleine
de sens pourquoi est-ce que je paye
autant d'impôts pour un service aussi
lamentable
pourquoi est-ce qu'on impose au secteur
hospitalier
la question de la rentabilité
encore et toujours pourquoi les services
des soignants ne peuvent-ils pas
bénéficié de formation en interne pour
évaluer et améliorer leurs pratiques
vous répondrez peut-être que le ségur de
la santé va tout changer ou que les
restrictions budgétaires imposées ces
difficultés mais c'est faux il est
question de choix politique la
revalorisation des salaires dans le
cadre du ségur sont insuffisantes
les créations de poste n'existe pas
véritablement car il s'il s'agit de
postes vacants et des services continus
ferme où fusionnent pour que les
fermetures et que les fermetures de lui
et hôpitaux se poursuivre il faut qu'on
arrête de parler pour rien dire et
surtout ne rien faire il faut
radicalement changé notre rapport au
système de soins j'ai rendre au peuple
son système de soins nous proposons des
mesures simples et en voici
quelques-unes revaloriser immédiatement
et sérieusement les salaires et pas par
des primes revaloriser les carrières des
soignants mettre en place un plan de
rénovation du parc hospitalier
titulariser l'ensemble des contractuels
à l'hôpital je termine réintégrer les
soignants démis de leurs fonctions merci
bien monsieur le député monsieur
thibault bazar non respectez bien les
deux minutes s'il vous plaît parce que
vous êtes très nombreux en général
permanent vous avez tout à fait respecté
monsieur le député monsieur thibault
bazin vous avez la parole merci madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre je
viens ce soir tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
concernant la situation financière
compliquée des ehpad compte tenu de
l'inflation en effet ils se trouvent eux
aussi confrontés à l'évolution inédite
du coût de l'énergie et des autres
charges mais le neuf peuvent répercuter
ces hausses en effet les négociants les
négociations passer des contrats
pluriannuels d'objectifs et de moyens se
sont faites sur des bases qui ne
prenaient pas encore en compte ces
augmentation soudaine des prix
imprévisible d'ailleurs et ces
établissements ne bénéficie pas du
bouclier tarifaire il faut noter aussi
que l'augmentation du smic aura aussi un
effet inflationniste sur les salaires
principalement pour les agents de
service hospitalier les ash et que cette
hausse ne sera pas non plus qu'on pense
et à ce stade par une augmentation des
dotations ce phénomène créé pour ces
établissements donc un effet de ciseaux
ou les ressources ne suivent pas les
dépenses pourtant incompréhensible cet
effet menace donc à court terme la
survie de ces structures est le
quotidien des résidants leurs capacités
financières s'amenuisent réduisant
d'autant leur capacité d'action et de
réaction face aux aléas je viens donc
vous demander monsieur le ministre
comment le gouvernement compte aider au
plus vite ces structures qui travaillent
déjà dans les conditions bien difficile
pour s'occuper au mieux nos aînés et
soulager ainsi leur famille de votre
dépend de votre réponse dépend ensuite
la réponse des départements sur les
sections hébergement et dépendent et
dépendances mais ils attendent des
positions des ars
sur cette équation financière
merci bien pour la concision de la
question également monsieur jérôme guedj
elle va être aussi con si je vais tâcher
madame la présidente
d'ailleurs je mets mon chronomètre parce
qu'ils marchent pas celui là donc pour
vérifier
un sujet qui n'a pas encore été abordée
monsieur le ministre et sur lequel je
suis je dois le dire un peu resté sur ma
faim à la lecture du rapport c'est la
question des urgences psychiatriques
une des mesures fortes phare que vous
préconisez c'est une incitation aux
établissements spécialisée à mettre en
place des dispositifs unifier un pardon
des ip unifiées intersectorielle quand
on connaît l'état de la psychiatrie
publique et la psychiatrie de secteur ça
ressemble je dois le dire quand même un
peu un voeu pieux et ça ne règle pas la
question des urgences psychiatrique à
l'hôpital à l'hôpital général même type
de remarques pour être fait sur la
question des urgences pédiatriques que
vous abordez uniquement sous le prisme
de la prime de risque ou du
développement des infirmières en
pratique avancée et ça me permet de
rebondir chez votre remarque que vous
avez fait à l'instant en dix ans les
modalités de financement de la réforme
des modalités de financement des
urgences sont très pertinentes il me
semble avoir vu passer une prise de
position unifiée des sociétés savantes
de pédiatrie du cnp de pédiatrie du spf
etc pointant précisément une que la
modalité de financement nouvelles
s'agissant de la pédiatrie et est
pénalisante par rapport aux adultes et
que par conséquent il y avait une
désincitation à aller sur ce terrain
troisième remarque c'est la question et
de je vous pose en direct est-ce qu'il
faut envisager des urgences gériatriques
c'est à dire une filière elle est
mentionnée dans le rapport mais jusqu'à
quel point elle peut être intégré
sachant que vous vous préconisez là
aussi de manière un peu incantatoire je
cite page 52 une attention particulière
doit être apportée à la médicalisation
des ehpad afin d'éviter des transports
adaptés vers les services d'urgence
générateur d'une morbidité mortalité
plus élevé là c'est très clairement la
question de la médicalisation dans les
ehpad et des moyens que vous pourrez y
développer comme il me reste dix
secondes madame la présidente deux
questions qui n'ont absolument rien à
voir vous avez dit que votre périmètre
c'est la prévention mais que la
prévention de la perte d'autonomie ses
cheveux monsieur combes dont l'un bien
que vous nous clarifier la répartition
des rôles entre le mini chargé de la
prévention et la question essentielle de
la perte d'autonomie qui est redondante
avec celle là est la dernière question
vous avez dix ans des mines vous allez
dire en 2000 très bien monsieur la grève
était légitime non s'il y avait une
grève si vous appuyez zeppelin
non merci bien j'ai dépassé de 12
secondes madame la présidente très bien
elle était très pertinente votre
question vos questions d'ailleurs
monsieur le député merci madame la
présidente voilà sur ce on passe au
suivant jean luc varman merci un
président que j'ai essayé de rattraper
les 12 secondes monsieur le ministre je
suis à tout d'abord avant tout à
féliciter pour votre nomination à vous
souhaiter la meilleure réussite est à
vous dire la volonté des ardennais de
poursuivre et d'amplifier le travail
initié avec votre ministère ces
dernières années face aux difficultés
économiques et sociales et à la baisse
démographique d'environ 400 habitants
par an les ardennais une liste où leurs
forces pour organiser le département
cette volonté a reçu le soutien du
gouvernement par la signature le 15 mars
2010 9 du pacte ardennes dans ce cas de
multiplions les innovations vue
d'assurer la meilleure offre médicale à
la population dans le contexte
géographique médical que chacun connaît
une des multiples solution réside dans
une formation complémentaire de deux ans
d'infirmiers diplômés d'état en vue
qu'ils acquièrent la compétence d'un tir
mis en pratique avancée je tiens à vous
dire mon soutien pour toutes les
modifications du sat yves réglementaires
à venir qui seront nécessaires dans la
région grand est ce de promotion de la
série pratiques avancées viennent d'être
formés grâce à votre adresse lors de
réunions entre avec le cabinet de votre
prédécesseur le 23 mai dernier j'ai
demandé la mise en place des
financements pour assurer dans région
grand est ce la formation de deux
nouvelles promotions j'ai également
demandé dans le cas du pacte ardennes
une expérimentation départementale
permettant proposé dès 2024 à chaque
maison pluridisciplinaire de santé et à
chaque centre de santé volontaires
l'affectation d'un infirmières pratiques
avancées se retourner si t'as garantie
qu'ils bénéficieront d'un employeur
respectant leur liberté professionnelle
il permettra le renforcement des liens
entre la médecine hospitalière la
médecine de ville monsieur le ministre
je souhaite pouvoir compter sur votre
soutien pour mettre en place ces mesures
et vous indique la disponibilité des
ardennes pour être un terrain
d'innovation d'expérimentation de votre
future politique de santé je vous
remercie merci bien monsieur le député
monsieur thomas meunier merci madame la
première présidente monsieur le ministre
les urgences sont révélateurs du système
de santé à l'interface entre la ville et
l'hôpital vous l'avez dit vous le
connaissez de l'intérieur et nous sommes
quelques-uns à le connaître également de
l'intérieur ici surtout ses bancs avant
votre rapport que je salue d'autres
nombreux étaient parus notamment le
pacte de refondation des urgences dont
la mise en oeuvre a été percuté par la
pandémie je salue vos propos sur le
service d'accès aux soins à généraliser
je l'appelle de mes voeux s'est
d'ailleurs déjà inscrit dans la loi
pouvez vous nous donner monsieur le
ministre des perspectives sur une autre
mesure du pacte de refondation la
possibilité de mettre en place des
antennes de médecine d'urgence qui
nécessite la prise d'un décret et qui
pourrait apporter de réelles réponses
sur de nombreux territoires par ailleurs
en complément et ensuite des différents
rapports remis le parlement notre
majorité a agi avec engagement depuis
cinq ans pouvez vous monsieur le
ministre nous donner des perspectives
sur la mise en oeuvre de la régulation
de l'intérêt médical que nous avons voté
dans le cadre de la loi risque ainsi
qu'un calendrier sur la prise de décret
de mesure de la loi à ma santé 2022
concernant la prise en charge de
pathologies du quotidien comme par
exemple la cystite en pharmacie pour
qu'elle rentre dans le quotidien des
français et améliorent leur accès aux
soins enfin dernière question vous avez
évoqué la conférence des parties
prenantes ou prévues à l'automne
comptez-vous y posée sans tabou sur la
table la question de la régulation de
l'installation des médecins je vous
remercie
merci bien monsieur le député madame
bénédicte aux anneaux
madame merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre dans un courrier en
date du 29 juillet dernier l'équipe des
urgences de l'hôpital de cavaillon dans
ma circonscription a alerté le directeur
général de la rs de ce qui suit à ce
jour le planning prévisionnel du mois
d'août va aboutir à la fermeture
complète trois journées et 11 nuits non
seulement des urgences mais également du
smur de cavaillon mettant grandement en
danger la population
les autres journées et nuits seront en
grande partie en fonctionnement dégradé
avec du personnel médical en moins
ces déclarations sont en contradiction
avec votre présentation d urgence cet
été
que pouvez-vous faire rapidement pour
aider les urgences de cavaillon à rester
ouvertes alors même que nous sommes en
pleine session touristique je vous
remercie merci bien madame la députée
monsieur jean hugues ratenon
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre les problèmes rencontrés dans
les urgences en hexagone sont aggravées
dans les outre-mer le constat est
unanime et tous les syndicats le disent
il y a urgence aux yeux jean ce manque
de personnel la prise en charge des
patients est très longue ce qui entraîne
des tensions des patients d'hommes
attendent des heures dans les couloirs
vont d'avoir traitement à cause des
fermetures de lits et des tic dans les
différents services à la réunion les
personnes âgées sont confrontés à un
autre problème celui du manque de
transport si l'ambulance et emmène aux
urgences elle ne les attend pas paul et
ramener elles doivent rester la plupart
du temps sur une civière et attendre le
jour se levait pour rentrer chez elle
nous assistons à une dégradation du
service public hospitalier faut-il faire
le lien avec l'étude de l'insee en juin
dernier qui révélait que à la réunion la
réunion est le département français qui
connaît la plus haute of hausse de décès
plus de 39 poisson sur la période du 1er
janvier au 23 mai 2000 22 par rapport à
2010 9
21,3 à mayotte 18 poisson en martinique
15 x 100 quads loup contre 6,8 ici dans
l'hexagone je souligne que les u 11 ans
à la réunion accueille des patients de
l'océan indien qui a aussi pour effet de
surcharger ses services avec des
personnel dévoué mais épuisé je les
salue d'ailleurs cette situation ne peut
plus durer nous voulons dans les
outre-mers l'hôpital humaniser aussi
monsieur le ministre le coefficient
géographique qui n'a pas été réévalué
depuis plus de 15 ans doit être la
solution
comme s'y est engagé d'ailleurs le
président de la république en début
d'année comptez vous traduire cette
promesse dans le prochain projet de loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale je
vous remercie pour votre réponse merci
bien monsieur yannick noah une der
moderne à la présidente monsieur nuit je
voudrais revenir sur toi point
concernant la mission flash tout d'abord
un constat quand même ça suppute que le
réseau de médecine libérale basé sur les
généralistes soient déjà tellement
organisé malheureusement moi sur mon
territoire eh bien je n'avais ni urgence
ni suffisamment de médecins généralistes
dont j'ai mis en place un centre de
soins non programmés et je vous
demanderai simplement ne pas être aussi
dur dans l'évaluation puisque c'est
quand même 80 consultation qui sont
effectués par jour c'est la seule
solution que j'ai trouvée en tant qu'élu
local et en tant que médecin pour faire
face à ses besoins de populations et ça
permet surtout de diminuer l'afflux aux
urgences notamment du chu de grenoble
sur son site de voir ans le deuxième
point c'est sur l'aspect volume je suis
pas tout à fait favorables quand vous
dites quand même que le numerus clausus
a été supprimée sanaa loin s'en faut
régler tous les problèmes puisque
malheureusement les étudiants ne peuvent
pas redoublé et vous le savez donc nous
avons vraiment des étudiants qui veulent
faire médecine et qui sont obligés de
partir à l'étranger en espagne en
roumanie où d'ailleurs les profs des
formations en français leur sont
proposés et que nous mêmes à l'hôpital
on passe notre temps à essayer de
recruter des médecins étrangers donc je
pense que il ya encore des mesures
d'adaptation à faire est pour et pour
illustrer le propos j'ai revu dans mon
hôpital les médecins de réanimation
médicale qui constate quand même une non
augmentation leurs effectifs on vient
d'avoir deux ans de crise qu vides et
les effectifs suite au classement
d'internât 95 médecins de réanimation
médicale de mire maintenant 101 donc il
ya eu création de six postes à l'échelon
national
ce qui est vraiment très peu quand on
sait que nous avons 400 postes en
réanimation vacants et qu'il faudrait
doubler les effectifs de formation enfin
le troisième point concerne
l'attractivité
on salue tous les infirmières en
pratique avancée mais je voudrais quand
même vous relayer l'inquiétude des
infirmiers anesthésistes qui
effectivement se sont vus refuser
d'intégrer ce dispositif au titre que
c'était essentiellement sur des maladies
chroniques or elles ont été assez étonné
de voir que fin 2019 et bien il y avait
une mention de médecine d'urgence et
elle demande simplement de pouvoir être
intégrée au code de la santé publique
sous le statut d'auxiliaire médicaux en
pratique à sans avancée qui a été
confirmé par une mission igas en janvier
2022 et pour lequel n'ont aucun retour
actuellement dont je pense que ça les
rassure est grandement ainsi que
l'ensemble des infirmiers anesthésistes
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame astrid pas notion bouvet
micro
merci madame la présidente là la
question rejoint celle de mon collègue
précédent sur le sur le numerus clausus
donc ce sera la même la même question
parce que le nombre de médecins par
habitant est resté le même qu'en 2006
malgré un vieillissement de la
population une augmentation des maladies
chroniques et une exposition maintenant
supérieures aussi à des à des épisodes
épidémiologique tel qu'on a pu les
connaître avec la crise du duc au vide
donc comment s'assurer que la hausse du
nombre d'étudiants admis répond bien aux
besoins des territoires sur le long
terme malgré la mise en place du numerus
à perthus qui a été mentionné est ce
qu'une révision des objectifs nationaux
pluriannuel est prévue est ma deuxième
question c'est la libération du temps
médical qui a souvent été mentionné pour
les médecins de nombreux professionnels
du paramédical est autorisé et réaliser
des actes ou administrer des soins qui
ne relèvent normalement pas de leur
attribution pendant la crise du coc vide
et donc l'alignement des compétences
effectives et des prérogatives est un
moyen de lutter contre les déserts
médicaux aucune gêne et généralement de
favoriser l'accès à la santé à la fois
en prévention comme vous avez pu souvent
le mentionner ou en traitement et est-ce
qu'on envisage de pérenniser ses
attributions temporaire et
éventuellement de les élargir
merci madame la députée monsieur
christophe bentz
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué la crise des
services d'urgence au début de votre
intervention il ya une autre urgence à
régler celle de la désertification
médicale qui s'accentue chaque jour en
particulier dans la réalité que ce soit
concernant le service public de la santé
ou la médecine libérale la médecine de
ville et de village un exemple en
haute-marne nous avons l'un des plus
faibles taux de médecins par habitant en
france
et nous subissons
simultanément un démantèlement de
l'hôpital de langres pourtant deuxième
ville de ma circonscription
un démantèlement d'ailleurs qui est
soutenu par le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez les français paient tous des
impôts et cotisations mais ils n'ont pas
tous le même accès aux soins il y a là
une rupture d'égalité dans cet accès
entre les métropoles et les zones
rurales cette situation est vécue comme
une réelle injustice
monsieur le ministre quel est votre
feuille de route exacte pour sauver le
système de santé je vous cite en crise
aiguë termes que vous avez employé au
début de cette audition et vos projets
concrets et en urgence pour développer
les services de santé publics et privés
et réduire ainsi la distance et le temps
entre les français et l'offre de soins
qu'ils sont en droit d'attendre je vous
remercie merci bien monsieur adria cloud
et
il est sorti
madame isabelle valentin
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre j'ai été ravi de vous entendre
parler de la prévention puisque ça a été
une grande oubliée pendant dix ans je
souhaite aujourd'hui attirer votre
attention sur l'intérêt médical en
juillet 2020 ministre olivier vers ans
s'était engagé à mettre fin à ce qu'il
appelait le mât sonar ya de l'intérêt
médical en encadrant pour de bon les
rémunération demandée par les
intérimaires aux établissements de santé
quand et comment comptez vous encadrer
de façon sérieuse cet intérêt médical
qui dans sa forme actuelle est en train
de mettre dangereusement en péril et
notre système de santé et nos
établissements ma deuxième question
concerne une meilleure répartition des
tâches entre les professionnels de santé
de façon transversale avec le manque
cruel de professionnels de santé il est
aujourd'hui urgent d'apporter de vraies
réponses et de prendre de vraies
décisions
pour cela il me paraît nécessaire que
notre système de santé se montre moins
corporates risque à mes yeux il y a des
solutions sur le long terme celle des
infirmiers en pratique avancée ce sont
des professionnels qui permettent une
meilleure qu'au abu ration des
professionnels de santé et ainsi
permettre de désengorger notre système
de santé donc monsieur le ministre quel
suite quelle évolution quelle importance
comptez-vous donner aux formations des
ip à qui donnerait un souffle et nos
systèmes de santé et ma dernière
question concerne les meuse les mesures
en fait qu'il faudrait prendre sur le
court terme et le long tu es le oui long
terme pour pallier au manque cruel de
médecins en zone rurale et pour sortir
au plus vite de la dangereuse crise d
urgence à savoir dans mon département à
médecins de ville en haute-loire gère en
moyenne 1500 patients ce qui est très au
dessus des seuils nationaux merci bien
monsieur didier le gac merci le
président de monsieur le ministre je
m'éloigne à peu des services d'urgence
pour aller vers les soins critiques pour
rappeler que le précédent gouvernement
avait créé une prime d'un montant de 118
euros bruts 100 euros net à l'intention
des infirmiers infirmières qui
travaillent dans ces structures
absolument essentiel unité de
réanimation réanimation néonatale unité
de soins intensifs unités néonatales
enfin tout ce qu'on appelle
effectivement donc les soins critiques
cette prime mensuelle avait constitué
bien évidemment une vraie reconnaissance
pour tous ces professionnels travaillant
au sein de services de soins très
souvent particulièrement délicate ma
question est simple est-ce que vous
pensez
étendre cette prime au z soignante parce
qu'effectivement dans les services de
réanimation les médecins réanimateurs
nous le disent nous le rappellent
régulièrement le couple un fermier est
soit notre absolument essentiel et les
aides soignants et aides soignantes ont
vécu cette date avoir été évident
d'avoir été exclus de la prime comme une
très grande injustice et donc je vous
remercie de
me dire que si vous pensez l'étendre aux
aides soignants merci merci monsieur le
député monsieur serge muller
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues je suis diplômé
aides soignants depuis 2003 j'ai exercé
exercer dans la fonction publique
hospitalière jusqu'à en juin 2022 vous
avez devant vous un aide soignant qui a
traversé la première vague le premier
confinement les contrôle de ses papiers
par les forces de l'ordre alors qu'il
allait travailler pour prendre soin de
nos anciens confiné eux aussi dans leur
propre chambre puis la deuxième vague et
ainsi de suite vous avez devant vous un
aide soignant qui a été dans
l'obligation de se faire vacciner à
défaut de perdre son emploi un hack
soignants qui s'est soumis aux règles
mais qui a vu ses collègues mais à pied
pour leurs convictions ou leur simple
inquiétudes des effets du vaccin vous
avez proposé la mise en place de la
prime ségur merci pour cette
reconnaissance
néanmoins le problème est plus profond
les conditions de travail des soignants
se dégrade cela décourage les
professionnels qui quittent leurs
fonctions dû à la fatigue causée par le
manque de cruel de soignants le manque
de personnel médical et paramédical
engendre une mauvaise prise en charge
des patients retard de la prise en
charge des malades et aggravent leur
état de santé
comment comptez vous attirer les jeunes
professionnels ou ceux qui voudraient se
reconvertir vers un système en plein
déclin aussi ne pensez vous pas que la
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
serait une piste envisageable merci
merci bien
madame rachel kéké cv la parole merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre la population est très inquiète
par le manque de soignants notamment les
services d'urgence la situation est
dramatique
les soignants fut l'hôpital public à
cause de ses conditions de travail
de nombreux services sont en
sous-effectifs pour accueillir les
patients dans de bonnes conditions
cent vingt sept agences en france dob
limiter leur activité à cause du manque
du personnel monsieur le ministre nous
parlons ici de la santé de nos
concitoyens
la vie n'a pas de prix l'hôpital se
meurent à cause coupes budgétaires
imposées par le gouvernement depuis des
années la fosse de l'hôpital c'est son
personnel le soignant dévoués qui
sacrifie pas voir le vie privée pour
fait tenir pital tour le précieux mais
aujourd'hui ils appellent à l'aide le
gouvernement semble par les écouter la
revalorisation des salaires du ségur de
la santé n'a pas suffi elle n'a pas
permis d'attirer plus de personnel ni de
les retenir les trois syndicats du seuil
manifesteront en septembre pour ouvrir
des négociations sérieuses sur les
conditions de travail la rémunération et
les effectifs allez vous les écoutez
quand est ce que en temps mais une
réelle politique de recrutement des
soignants
quant à ce qu'on leur accorde la
reconnaissance et les moyens matériels
dont ils ont besoin quand est-ce qu'on
revenus mais à la juste valeur du
travail qu'ils fournissent monsieur le
ministre
n'en souffre monsieur le ministre la
population a peur d'aller à l'hôpital
quand les malades parce qu'elles ont
peur de mourir merci très bien madame
fanta bérété merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre selon le rapport de
votre mission flash 133 services
d'urgence sont en situation de
difficulté savoir manque de médecins
d'infirmiers et d'aides-soignants ou de
lits cela représente environ 21 45 % des
quelque six cent vingt établissements
tout france comprise l'ensemble du
territoire national et toucher la
mission flash que vous avez conduite à
formuler quarante et une recommandation
à partir d'un travail approfondi sur le
terrain auprès des professionnels
praticiens ce travail nous livre ici les
enjeux dans toutes leurs dimensions en
ce qui concerne notamment les réponses
d'urgence merci beaucoup cela étant je
m'interroge sur le temps long tout en me
réjouissant que notre gouvernement était
celui qui a supprimé le numerus clausus
qu'en est-il réellement de
l'attractivité de ces métiers cruciaux
pour le maintien de nos services
d'urgence sur tout le territoire
national tant au niveau de la formation
des conditions de travail et des
salaires
merci bien madame la députée notamment
pour la concision en plus de la
pertinence de votre question je passe la
parole à monsieur françois ruffin merci
même présente dans ma ville à amiens
l'hôpital se faire et victor accueille
les personnes âgées deux services
viennent de fermer je cite une
infirmière on était tous en pleurs ici
quand on a un vieux monsieur qui ne vous
lâche pas la main qui s'accroche à son
lit qui nous critiquent m'abandonne ça
pèse sur le moral du jour au lendemain
il a fallu les faire partir ils ont donc
été expulsé leur lieu de vie
des questions simples est ce que vous
allez procéder à des embauches dans tous
les hôpitaux de pays qu'on quel est
votre plan combien de milliers combien
de dizaines de milliers d'embûches quand
c'est la question vous est posée par des
journalistes la réponse est pour le
moins fuyante et pas clair ensuite j'ai
apprécié dans votre propos ce que vous
avez dit des infirmières en formation
vous à dire voilà il y en a beaucoup qui
quitte la formation pourquoi parce que
leurs bourses on a du mal à les avoir
elles sont trop maigres quand elles
partent en stage elles n'ont pas les
moyens de payer stage ça du coup ça
valide notre proposition d'une
allocation d'autonomie pour les
étudiants et la nécessité d'avoir un
revenu de formation pendant ce temps là
parce qu'on voit bien qu'en fonctionnant
à l'économie sur les études qu'est ce
que ça fait ça désorganise le système ça
installe le chaos et enfin vous avez dit
que et en fond il y avait un fossé entre
ce qu'elle recevait en formation s quand
elle voyait quand elle est arrivée à
l'hôpital et qu'elle percevait de la
maltraitance et votre proposition pour
sortir de ça c'est de dire on va revoir
les formations au fond est ce qu'il
s'agit de revoir les formations pour les
habitués de l'école à la maltraitance
très bien je passe la parole à monique
iborra
merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre on a bien entendu
votre votre énergie qui ce qui se
manifestait et ce volontarisme qui est
en effet de vouloir régler ce problème
qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui le
problème des urgences je me rappelle un
temps si lointain où je participais
au ministère de la santé déjà sur ce
type de thèmes qui étaient pas réglé moi
ce qui me frappe c'est que nos
politiques publiques monsieur le
ministre n'arrive pas à diffuser jusqu'à
nos citoyens et que les gens ne savent
pas quelles sont nos politiques
publiques ce que nous poursuivons comme
nous mettons en place et je crois qu'il
faut peut-être se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi on doit trouver de
réponse d'autre part je me suis j'ai
essayé de voir sur ces deux mois qu'elle
avait été l'utilisation du 15 sur mon
département très peu très peu parce que
les gens ne sont pas au courant donc la
communication reste quelque chose qu'on
ne sait pas faire probablement mais je
pense qu'au delà de la manière de la
faire je crois que ce sont pas le
nommant deux personnes de nombre
d'acteurs qui manquent mais bien de
savoir qui coordonne quoi et donc ma
question est la suivante
à partir de ce que vous voulez faire
monsieur le ministre à qui allez vous
confier la coordination de l'ensemble de
cette politique que voulait mettre sur
les territoires dernière chose par
rapport aux ehpad mois par rapport aux
ehpad au delà du fait qu'il faut les
médicalisé ça aboutisse et paraissant on
en parle depuis longtemps
actuellement dans les ehpad il y à
vraiment des abus avec le recours de
l'intérim honnêtement des tarifs
prohibitifs des pratiques déloyales des
agences d'intérim et donc avant de
penser à recruter il faut voir un peu
comment se passent les choses et
intervenir parce que nous n'arrivons pas
à en recruter dans les états de jaune
très bien madame la députée madame
farida amrani excusé malaisie jeunes
interrompent à on poursuit en madame
farida mme amrani vous avez la parole
bien merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je souhaitais vous parler de
la situation du centre hospitalier sud
francilien qui assure la couverture
hospitalière depuis de six cent mille
habitants en essonne et en seine seine
et marne il lui manque aujourd'hui 110
postes d'infirmières 20 postes de sages
femmes et cinq postes de
kinésithérapeute 140 lits fermés cet été
pour des raisons de manque du personnel
j'aimerais également évoqué la
problématique de la maternité de cet
hôpital plus de cinq mille naissances
par an dans cette bande dans celui ci
pourtant aujourd'hui au nom je vous
parle il manque 25 postes de fans de
sages-femmes ces femmes enceintes
plusieurs ont reçu des courriers de
refus de suivi de leur accouchement où
vont-elles accouché monsieur le ministre
dans des cliniques privées ou peut-être
dans un de vos bus itinérant francs
service j'aimerais également aussi
parler de la problématique du matériel
et notamment d'un robot un robot
chirurgical ou où il est demandé aux
collectivités de participer fortement à
cet achat on ne connaît pas le prix qui
varient entre 2 millions et 3 millions
par contre après recherche faite il
s'est avéré que l'état a quand même
débourser la 52 millions d'euros sur
sept ans pour financer l'acquisition de
neuf robots chirurgicaux mais que dans
la dans les hôpitaux parisiens pourquoi
n'avez vous pas pris en charge un de 7
ce robot pour pour notre département de
l'essonne pourquoi demander vos
collectivités de participer et refusez
vous les personnes qui appartiennent aux
qui habitent sur ces territoires et vous
utilisez en fait tout simplement leur
argent l'argent de leurs impôts locaux
l'hôpital sud francilien amsud ministre
est en crise depuis de nombreuses années
quelle mesure entendez vous prendre pour
pallier ces manquements rapidement et de
façon concrète merci beaucoup
merci monsieur nicolas turquois merci
madame la présidente
bonjour monsieur le ministre est heureux
de d'échangé pour vous et que la
première fois je voudrais saluer la
qualité de de votre rapport parce que au
delà des positions dogmatiques sur
l'hôpital va mal il n'y a pas assez de
médecins une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a
pas avancé sur un sujet vous avez essayé
d'identifier des situations qui
ressortent du lot et
c'est un député de la vienne qui vous
parlez donc qui a été un petit peu
biberonné avec le ce qui se passe à
poitiers mais c'est vrai que quand il ya
du dialogue du dialogue entre les
différentes parties on avance quand il
ya du dialogue au sein de l'hôpital
entre la logique non programmée des
urgences et la logique programmée de
l'hôpital proprement dit on peut arriver
à faire converger les intérêts avec le
band management et je je je confirme que
c'est une initiative très très utile qui
fait gagner beaucoup de temps et qui
limite beaucoup le nombre de lits dans
dans les couloirs quand on fait
dialoguer avec les élus on peut
rapprocher les différents hôpitaux et ça
permet au chu de poitiers et à l'hôpital
de châtellerault d'assurer le
fonctionnement des urgences et des soins
non programmés des hôpitaux secondaire
de loudun et de montmorillon qui a du
sens de discuter donc ce dialogue cette
coopération sa puissance moi je vais
évoquer trois points par rapport à ce
que vous avez dit c'est une forme de
décrédibilisation du 15 pour un certain
nombre de patients qui ont perdu on
n'appelle plus le 15 parce que parce
qu'on va nous plutôt nous chercher à
nous à nous repousser des urgences
la question des pratiques avancées c'est
évoqué par ma collègue isabelle valentin
qui me semblent prometteuses pour
pour suppléer le manque de médecins
qu'on a à court terme et puis la
dernière chose comment est-ce que la rs
peut initier cette culture du dialogue
entre différents établissements
hospitaliers entre hospitalier et
médecine de ville et entre hospitalier
et territoires est élu je vous remercie
merci bien la parole est un madame marie
charlotte gare à
monsieur le ministre je vous adresse la
question de monsieur le député sébastien
péta vick ne peut assister à nos travaux
en raison d'une hospitalisation en
raison de la pénurie de médecins et pour
la troisième fois consécutive depuis le
début de l'été le centre hospitalier de
sarlat l'hôpital de sa circonscription a
été contraints de fonctionner en mode
dégradé via le quinze du 27 juillet au
31 juillet 2022 l'accueil des urgences
fut clos selon un récent rapport du
sénat le nombre de passages ce a doublé
en l'espace de trente ans les activités
augmente les moyens baissent les
conditions de travail se dégradent les
médecins s'en vont la situation des
services d'urgence est une illustration
de la dégradation continue des
conditions d'exercice et à l'hôpital
public à l'hôpital cette pénurie de
personnel a fait exploser le recours à
la pratique dite du mercenariat ces
mercenaires de la santé en intérim
assure des vacations à des salaires
importants voire mirobolants si cette
rémunération est censé être encadrés
dans les faits les montants prévus sont
rarement respectées et très largement
supérieur aux salaires des praticiens
hospitaliers
cette pratique délétère n'incite pas à
l'engagement des médecins à l'hôpital
public d'une part alloué des moyens
supplémentaires aux universités de
médecine permettrait de rendre effective
l'ouverture du mieux ce qu aux us et
d'autre part revalorisé les gardes
hospitalière favoriserait les
titularisations à l'hôpital monsieur le
ministre je sais que vous avez à coeur
le fonctionnement des services d'urgence
en témoignent les quarante et une
recommandation pour cet été issues de la
mission flash qui vous avait été confié
mais l'heure est à la mise en place de
solution structurelle et non
conjoncturelle
mon collègue sébastien peytavi
souhaiterait donc savoir ce que le
gouvernement entend faire pour mettre
fin à ces pratiques et redonner de
l'attractivité à l'hôpital je vous
remercie merci bien la parole est à
monsieur élie califer
le micro micro voilà merci madame
présidente monsieur le ministre c'est un
ancien président la fédération
hospitalière de la guadeloupe qui vous
pas et je suis bien heureux écoutez le
système de soins est défaillant le dit
tous
mais en guadeloupe
il se pose avec une acuité particulière
et désespèrent la démographie médicale
et les ressources ont tendance à quitter
à fuir le chu guadeloupe
monsieur le ministre ma question porte
le financement structurel des hôpitaux
en outre-mer et singulièrement en
guadeloupe jouer se tait connaître votre
position sur la revalorisation du
coefficient géographique
qui permettrait vous le savez de
compenser nos handicaps structurels et
donc de donner aux urgences les moyens
de fonctionner d'accueillir et de sauver
des vies dans un département à
pathologies chroniques
j'attends votre réponse merci à vous
merci bien la parole est à nicole du bre
chirat merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre le personnel
soignant et l'organisation des
établissements hospitaliers ou été mis à
rude épreuve pendant l'épidémie de kovy
d' alors même que leur état de santé
n'était pas au beau fixe auparavant
depuis nous devons faire face une
fatigue voire un épuisement qui entraîne
une fuite des soignants médicaux et
paramédicaux n'ont pas vers d'autres
secteurs de soins mais vers d'autres
horizons le segura permis d'apporter du
matériel de rénover des locaux
d'améliorer la gouvernance de
revaloriser les salaires mais il n'a pas
permis d'arrêter l'hémorragie
aujourd'hui les places vacantes dans les
instituts de formation les postes
vacants dans les établissements de santé
les problèmes de recrutement le manque
d'attractivité doublé des insuffisances
d'installation de médecins en milieu
rural malgré ces aides financières
incitatives entraîne des fermetures de
lits par manque de personnel ou pour des
problèmes autres le report des patients
se fait sur les urgences seul lieu
ouvert accessible et gratuit ce qui
sature totalement le système hospitalier
et ce depuis de nombreuses années votre
rapport fait une quarantaine de
propositions pour une orientation plus
adaptée des patients le travail en
complémentarité des différents secteurs
le partage d'activités la reconnaissance
de la pénibilité dans l'exercice
professionnel et des augmentations de
salaires pensez vous que ces
propositions d'actions peuvent être
efficaces temporaire ou pérennes
suffisante pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins et sa continuité tout en soutenant
les professionnels dans cette période
difficile
d'autre part le secteur de santé mentale
est aussi en difficulté du fait de
l'augmentation de la demande de soins et
de la diminution de l'offre nous
assistons sur le territoire à des
fermetures de lits faute de médecin
psychiatre ce qui entraîne une
répartition des patients sur le
territoire régional quelles mesures
d'accompagnement pensez vous prendre
pour mieux adapter la réponse aux
besoins je remercie mr si bien d'un
député madame josiane corneloup merci
madame la présidente monsieur ministre
le système centre de santé est en grande
difficulté la crise des urgences n'a pas
grand chose avec les avoir avec les
seuils d'urgence vous l'évoquez mais
bien avec l'ensemble du système de santé
je me réjouis de votre souhait de
développer une politique de prévention
en fonte et je crois que c'est un enjeu
important pour les années à venir on
regarde l'allongement de la durée de vie
et de l'accroissement des pathologies
chroniques 2 millions de français n'ont
plus de médecin traitant certains
d'entre eux se tournent donc vers les
urgences hospitalières
lorsqu'ils ont un besoin il faut sans
attendre soulager les services d'urgence
par un rétablissement des capacités en
aval ceci a été évoquée nous connaissons
le peu d'attrait pour la médecine
générale si l'attrait de la profession
n'augmente pas très rapidement une
estimation de l'union européenne révèle
que 13 5 % des besoins en santé risquent
de ne pas être couvert en particulier
dans les territoires ruraux
envisagez-vous de revaloriser la
médecine générale en en faisant une
vraie spécialité rémunéré au même tarif
que les autres spécialités
ne pensez-vous pas également qu'il faut
accroître les stages dans les
territoires ruraux au sein des cabinets
libéraux
l'éducation et l'orientation des
patients sont également des pistes bien
évidemment à étudier un certain nombre
de patients qui arrivent aux urgences
pourrait bénéficier de soins dispensés
dans les officines nous avons 22000
officines
réparties sur le territoire national qui
représente un formidable atout au même
titre d'ailleurs que les maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaires
vous évoquiez améliorer la rémunération
des médecins libéraux qui participent à
la permanence des soins nous le savons
aujourd'hui beaucoup de médecins
libéraux ne participe pas à la
permanence des soins envisagez-vous de
la rendre obligatoire
vous évoquez à voir associer tous les
acteurs dans le cadre de cette mission
flash ars collectivités élus médecins
libéraux urgentiste les sapeurs pompiers
n'ont apparemment pas été associé à
l'élaboration des mesures que vous avez
recommandé alors qu'ils sont concernés
notamment par la recommandation 7 et la
recommandation 21
vous évoquez à la recommandation numéro
un le souhait de de réguler par le biais
du 15 j'ai conduit une mission
d'information sur les carences
ambulancière j'ai à cette occasion
auditionné plateformes en haute savoie
qui réunissait le 15 le 18 ou le 112 et
115 depuis plus de vingt ans et qui
était extrêmement pertinente je voulais
savoir pourquoi cette solution elle
n'avait pas été recommandée très bon
madame la députée j'ai été généreuse
voilà ça mange attend le retour des
collègues qui sont allés voter en fait
pour donner après la parole à monsieur
le ministre vous profiter un petit peu
de la situation et comme les deux
derniers ne sont pas là je vais
toutefois passer la parole cette fois ci
à jean françois rousse et je vous donne
le micro monsieur le député ainsi de
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
on a tous dans nos territoires des
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires qui
sont vides et des hôpitaux canam a du
mal à remplir dans la troisième
circonscription de l'aveyron et dans ce
cas mais on a une chance on va
bénéficier d'un hôpital commun
l'état va investir 80 millions d'euros
et la région 9 millions d'euros ma
question est la suivante comment arriver
à recruter à fidéliser des spécialistes
dans ce futur hôpital et je voudrais
vous faire une proposition est peut-être
vous la soute un sou trendrr y y et j'ai
pris l'initiative
d'intégrer très tôt de proposer
l'intégration très tôt des futurs
spécialistes en les prenant au début de
leur spécialité dans la construction du
projet médical de l'hôpital voilà faire
une co-construction
j'ai donc rencontré les chefs de service
de chirurgie puisque c'est la spécialité
que j'organisais que j'exerçais et j'ai
reçu un accueil très favorable à la fois
ces chefs de service et des gens avec
lesquels j'ai travaillé dans le
territoire alors serait-il possible d'en
faire une véritable expérimentation est
ce que cette expérimentation souhaite
être serait reproductive dans d'autres
territoires
tout ça dans l'optique de mettre un peu
plus d'humains et intégrer le projet
médical au milieu de tout ce maquis
administratif
serait-il possible de le
décliner au niveau d'une région d'un
département car je suis persuadé que
c'est la bonne façon de construire et de
co construire voilà merci merci bien
monsieur le député monsieur alexandre
vers son père je vous donne le micro
prenez le merci madame l'imposante
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit en
propos liminaire qu'il fallait se baser
sur le besoin plutôt que sur l'offre en
tant que député de la 7e circonscription
j'ai quelques cas pratique donc je
souhaite vous faire part
je vois par exemple dans la commune dont
je suis encore mr deux sujets
premièrement nous sommes dans la
métropole de lyon dans un territoire qui
gagnent des habitants et dans le même
temps nous avons eu à déplorer
il ya de ça quelques semaines la
fermeture d'une maternité alors certes
c'était de maternité d'un groupe privé
natecia pour ne pas le nommer mais elle
a fait la ferme et alors même que nous
avons rencontré les praticiens les
patients les sages-femmes et
propriétaire de la clinique est
simplement pour des raisons comptables
ils ont préféré fermer laissant un petit
peu dans le dénuement un bassin de
population qui pour autant à extrêmement
besoins et bien d'un site pour pouvoir
pour que les passions depuis sa couche
est premièrement deuxièmement en tant
que maire d'une ville où il ya un cul pv
important il ya un vrai sujet aussi qui
est le traitement notamment de la
psychiatrie vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que sur le site de bron et sur lyon il
ya le vinatier centre de psychiatrie
important et dans le même temps on le
voit aujourd'hui la psychiatrie
notamment dans les culs pv est hors
souffrance si je prends l'exemple
dcmp notamment pour le cmp pour les plus
jeunes pour les plus jeunes enfants
aujourd'hui on peut aujourd'hui observé
qu'il faut pour un jeune enfant environ
deux ans pour être prises en charge et
aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on puisse mettre les moyens parce que
notamment équipé on a une concentration
de populations en difficulté qui attend
être prise en charge et puis
dernièrement dernière dernier point
également si je prends le secteur de
bron sur le site de ma circonscription
qui colle à l'hôpital desgenettes qui
est certes un hôpital militaire mais qui
avait quatre quasiment 80 % de sa
patientèle qui étaient civils on est
passé de près
2 820 praticiens en 2018 à une petite
centaine alors certes c'est un hôpital
qui dépend du ministère des armées
cependant ces 80% aujourd'hui de la
population qui bénéficiait de cette
offre de soins qui pourra plus
bénéficier je vous remercie très bien
merci monsieur le député donc je vais à
présent donner la parole à monsieur le
ministre qui peut déjà répondre aux
questions des personnes qui sont déjà là
je vous de voila voila
c'est à dire la fin est un monsieur
descendait monsieur didier le gag
monsieur thomas minier voilà donc à
moins que vous préfériez ben tant pis on
démarre fait au plus simple à monsieur
le ministre c'est moi qui vous
compliquer un petit peu la faire mais
allez-y oui merci madame la présidente
va effectivement je pense que une
réponse globale comme vous m'aviez
demandé au départ et peut-être que je
vais quand même essayer de ne rien
oublier parce que
richesse de vos questions montre en tout
cas me renforce dans l'idée que nous
avons énormément à travailler sur ce
sujet que c'est une préoccupation
majeure de nos concitoyens et je vous
remercie de d'aller au plus profond des
problématiques pour que nous puissions
trouver ensemble des solutions alors
première question était au cours du
transfrontalier certes franco suisse
mais étant de moselle je suis
particulièrement concernée aussi par le
transfrontalier
franco-luxembourgeois avec pour le coup
une pompe aspirante du luxembourg
financière bien plus importante encore
que la suisse donc une problématique que
l'on connaît bien effectivement
concernant ce sujet particulier un
groupe de travail spécifique a été mis
en place suite à l'engagement du premier
ministre jean castex avec plusieurs
réunions dont deux réunions encore
dernièrement et qui a travaillé sur ces
effectivement trois sujets sur les
conditions de travail sur la formation
et sur l'offre de soins on va les
laisser continuer à travailler je ne
doute pas que ces travaux pourront être
repris et pourront être utilisés sur
d'autres secteurs transfrontalier
profiter de cette occasion aussi pour
dire un mot sur l'importance du
transfrontalier l'importance à mes yeux
d'une europe de la santé si nous
n'avions pas eu dans le conteste nos
collègues allemands qui ont pris en
charge presque 200 patients de
réanimation ça aurait été extrêmement
difficile et je crois que nous avons
tout intérêt d'ailleurs l'europe et l'om
est-ce dans sa partie
paneuropéenne travaille justement sur
ces coopérations et ses situations donc
il faut il faut les saluer
vous me permettrez
permettrait de ne pas prendre les cas
précis les uns après les autres en
fonction de ce qui a été demandé de
répondre de façon un petit peu plus
globale et il a été évoqué la
problématique des urgences pédiatriques
des urgences psychiatriques également la
question éventuellement d'urgence
gériatrique alors dans le cadre des
urgences vous le savez il s'agit des
autorisations d'activité de services
d'urgence dans ces autorisations il ya
les champs effectivement de de la
pédiatrie d urgence dit général et la
psychiatrie a une particularité un petit
peu par rapport à ça ma préoccupation et
les global quand on parle d urgence ce
n'est d'ailleurs pas que sur les
urgences mais aussi sur les maternités
elle est aussi sur la santé mentale que
vous êtes plusieurs à avoir relevé et la
santé mentale dans notre pays est en
très grosse difficultés sur les urgences
d'une façon plus générale l'ensemble des
mesures vous l'avez vu s'adresse à tous
les services d'urgence quel que soit
qu'ils soient pédiatrique qu'ils soient
où qu'ils soient psychiatrique est
d'ailleurs sur le financement pénalisant
qui a été qui a été relevé par les
sur les urgences pédiatriques
je connais bien le sujet pour avoir
discuté avec les pédiatres et je
m'inscris en faux sur 7 sur cette
constatation
ça a été d'ailleurs travaillé il y as
non pas un sous financement des urgences
pédiatriques mais une sous-déclaration
des effectifs médicaux et paramédicaux
dans les urgences pédiatriques qui
elle-même entraîne de fait ce
sous-financement les professionnels avec
la dg os travaille dessus sur un petit
peu là la révision de ses effectifs mais
il n'est en rien une volonté de sous
financement des urgences pédiatriques
quant à l'existence d' urgences
gériatriques
je crois qu'il faut arrêter de faire des
urgences surtout la spécificité des
patients gériatrique en termes de
pathologies c'est surtout qu'il ya des
polypathologies est ce assez pris en
charge par des urgences par contre avoir
des filières qui prennent en charge
comme je le disais tout à l'heure les
personnes âgées est quelque chose
d'essentiel et dans ces filières en
particulier pour répondre à la
problématique de la sous médicalisation
des ehpad je suis
en train de suivre de très près et je
suis très positif sur la mise en place d
ip et en particulier des péages
gériatrique ça a été évoqué sur
plusieurs questions cette question des
ip ah oui bien sûr il faut développer
les hyper il est tout à fait logique que
nous ayons une profession entre une
infirmière qui a trois ans d'études et
un docteur qui a 14 ans d'études ou 12
ans d'études il ya là un gap qu'il faut
combler les ip a qui ont déjà été créés
qui existent déjà montre tout leur
intérêt et toute leur utilité et je suis
en tout cas partisans de ce
développement bien entendu en lien avec
les spécialités concernées pour ne pas
développer des hypers qui ne serait pas
efficace à ce sujet on a également parlé
des iade des infirmières anesthésistes
diplômés d'état qui souhaitent intégrer
la filière ipea il ya un rapport igas en
fait il ya un travail en cours de l'igas
avec la présentation professionnelle qui
n'est toujours pas finie qui est en
cours et j'attends ses conclusions
justement pour savoir sous quelle forme
cela pourrait se mettre en place sachant
quand même que dans la formation du pays
il y à une formation d'une année
qui est une formation de base qui
reprend des principes de physiologie et
d'anatomie qui est indispensable et que
cette formation une année de base n'est
pas une formation qu'ont actuellement
les infirmières comme les iade donc il
ya certainement des choses à des choses
à compléter
concernant les questions sur le décret
sur les antennes de médecine d'urgence
donc ce décret est au conseil d'état sur
la réforme des autorisations d urgence
au sens large et les antennes en font
partie mais force est de constater que
dans cette période estivale le principe
des antennes et déjà mis en place de
façon certes dérogatoire mais elle va
nous permettre de les évaluer de façon
pertinente et de toute façon c'est une
bonne idée je rappelle quand même que
sur les antennes de médecine d'urgence
il y a ces services devront être intégré
un service d'urgence de pleine activité
dans le cadre d'une logique territoriale
pour ce qui est des traitements par tuer
la cystite en pharmacie dans le cadre de
ma santé 2022 il ya déjà un décret de
2021 qui autorise à le faire sur
certaines pathologies tout ce qui
concerne les transferts de tâches et les
transferts de compétences c'est
typiquement un sujet qui va être traité
dans la conférence des parties prenantes
il va falloir que chacun avance sur des
bases que je souhaite scientifique pour
ça pour qu'on soit certain qu'il ait pas
de perte de chance selon les patients ce
qui était le cas déjà sur les
pathologies dont on a parti alors
l'intérim ailleurs plusieurs plusieurs
questions autour de l'intérim
déjà nous avons un cadre réglementaire
la loire east de modernisation du
système de santé qui est limite cet
intérim il n'y a pas eu d'application de
ce texte sur la pression des
hospitaliers qu'ils soient directeurs et
qu'ils soient où qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient médecins mais j'aimerais partager
avec vous une vision un peu différente
de cette problématique de l'intérim
l'intérim c'est comme de la morphine en
tout cas je le présente toujours comme
ça c'est à dire que quand on va mal on
prendre la morphine ça va mieux et puis
comment on règle pas la pathologie comme
règle pas le problème mais on en prend
de plus en plus de la morphine et après
on en devient totalement dépendants
c'est un peu ce qui se passe avec
l'intérim il faut pas jeter la pierre à
l'intérim l'intérim en lui même n'est
que un symptôme ou en tout cas le
traitement symptomatique d'une maladie
plus importante qui est je le dis et je
le répète la maladie de notre système de
santé donc oui il faut lutter contre l
intérim ou oui il faut appliquer cette
loi que vous avez voté mais il faut
aussi l'appliquer de façon éclairée et
soignées en même temps la pathologie si
on arrête le traitement ne cautionne pas
la pathologie et bien ça allait de mal
en pis et c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
s'en sortir
la régulation à l'installation n'est pas
un sujet tabou et ne sera pas un sujet
tabou dans le cadre des discussions à
venir aucun sujet ne sera tabou
d'ailleurs il faut les mettre sur la
table il faut les il faut les travailler
il faut les travailler tous ensemble ce
que je souhaite c'est que nous ayons
nous ayons le temps de les mettre sur la
table comme je voulais dit la
temporalité de la conférence des parties
prenantes elle va nous emmener jusqu'à
2002 début 2000 23 je souhaite que nous
puissions travailler très en amont avec
vous sur l'ensemble de ces sujets et
peut-être éviter des décisions
précipitées qui qui mettrait en
difficulté
la discussion dans le cadre de la
conférence des parties prenantes sais
c'est le cas sur les déserts médicaux
dont on a dont on a parlé et là aussi
sur les déserts médicaux méfions-nous de
solution facile il ya qu'à faut qu'on il
ya une solution qui va tout régler non
il n'y a pas une solution qui va tout
régler c'est un panel de solutions dans
ce panel de solutions et dias a été
évoqué la réalisation de stages dès le
début des études bien entendu de
réalisation de plus de stages en
périphérie est probablement moins en chu
tout ça sont des éléments qui doivent
ressortir d'un conférence des parties
prenantes il y a aussi et et c'est en ça
que les élus sont concernés l'accueil
des étudiants dans ces stages il n'ya
plus d'internât avec les hôpitaux donc
on a des étudiants qui doivent faire des
stages à une heure une heure et demie de
route de chez eux qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se louer un deuxième
appartement à 150 km de la fac enfin
bref
la problématique est global et il faut
qu'on apprenne de façon globale avec là
aussi un principe de de boîte à outils
concernant les outre-mer je suis vous le
savez particulièrement attentif sur la
problématique des outre-mer le sujet il
ya eu un rapport sur le sujet des
coefficients géographique un rapport du
sénat si mes souvenirs au parlement déjà
sur sur ce sujet et donc nous nous
travaillons dessus pour voir et préciser
exactement les variabilités à introduire
de ces coefficient géographique
concernant les transports sanitaires qui
ont été évoqués nous a pas échappé que
il ya une réforme des transports
sanitaires urgents que cette réforme est
probablement en dessous des besoins
c'est pour ça que dans le cadre des
mesures d'été nous avons élargi d'au
moins 10% les besoins horaires pour ses
transports sanitaires urgents pour
justement donner un petit peu un petit
peu d'air
quand je parle des centres de soins
immédiats non programmé c'est pas pour
les condamner de façon de façon stricte
je les dis ils répondent à un besoin
simplement là aussi ne répondent pas
c'est un traitement plus symptomatique
que franchement un traitement sur
l'ensemble de la pathologie
concernant le numerus clausus qui a été
supprimée jeu là je le répète après des
dizaines d'années de maintien le numéro
sa part tous peut-être ne résout pas
tout il n'ya pas de redoublement certes
il n'y a pas de redoublement mais ça
c'est un cadre universitaire il n'y a
pas qu'en médecine qu'il n'y a pas de
redoublement et puis pour augmenter le
nombre d'étudiants mais il faut aussi
augmenter le nombre de formateurs il
faut aussi augmenter le nombre
d'enseignants il faut aussi augmenter le
nombre d'hospitalisations terre donc là
aussi quand on commence à tirer la
pelote c'est pas si simple et c'est bien
à tous les endroits et à tous les noeuds
du problème qu'il faut s'atteler en ce
qui concerne les effectifs des
différentes spécialités où il faut
probablement augmenter dans plein de
spécialité mais là c'est une vision qui
est plus que beaucoup plus globale et
dans l'état actuel des choses même avec
une augmentation des nombres d'étudiants
qui sont reçus à l'examen classant
national si on augmente une spécialité
forcément on diminue dans une autre donc
là aussi et je compte très clairement
dans l'évaluation des besoins non
seulement de santé mais également des
besoins de professionnels de santé et de
spécialités médicales dans les années à
venir je rappelle que si on évalue les
besoins par exemple pour les médecins
attends civis tu es bien il faut
réfléchir à 15 ans à 20 ans et à 30 ans
est pas un ou deux ans donc c'est bien
en fonction des besoins qu'il faudra
définir maintenant les spécialités en
tout cas de façon beaucoup plus précise
libérer du temps médical oui bien
entendu c'est le sujet des transferts de
tâches et de compétences ce sujet de
transfert de ta ses compétences c'est un
des sujets j'en suis certain qu'il va
émerger de façon importante dans la
conférence des parties prenantes je les
dis il faudra guetter professionnels
autour de la même table tous les
professionnels pour que ces transferts
de compétences se fasse en respectant
les règles de la science ne pas oublier
aussi les assistants médicaux je
rappelle que les assistants médicaux on
vient d'avoir les résultats permettent
d'augmenter de 10% la clientèle la
médecin qui a un accident médical qui
fait ce travail administratif ça c'est
en libéral je compte aussi diminué de
travail administratif des soignants à
l'hôpital qui pour certains d'entre eux
considèrent au moins 50% de leur travail
et leur redonner du temps soignants
c'est un des objectif principal
la désertification médicale j'en ai
parlé l'intérim également la prime la
prime concernant les soins critiques
elle est dans une logique et je les dis
que j'accepte qui est la logique de la
pénibilité de reconnaître la pénibilité
de certains métiers trente mille
infirmiers ont été concédées ont été
intégrés dans cette prime qui a
d'ailleurs été transposée dans le privé
et nous nous travaillons nous regardons
sur l'extension de cette prime c'est
dans une logique beaucoup plus globale
je les dis je le répète de la
reconnaissance de la pénibilité il ya
des métiers qui sont plus pénibles à
l'hôpital il y à la nuit qui publie
bilal week end plus pénible c'est une
vision là aussi globale qu'il faut avoir
je souhaite et vous l'avez compris
sortir de vision corporatiste quelles
qu'elles soient à l'hôpital comme au
dehors de l'hôpital pour avoir une
vision beaucoup plus générale et globale
sur les problèmes de santé je ne
reviendrai pas sur la réintégration des
soignants j'en ai j'en ai déjà parlé sur
les conditions de travail les
sous-effectifs vous avez compris que les
conditions de travail sont là aussi un
axe fort de la réforme que je veux
conduire il faut redonner du sens à
notre métier redonner du sens c'est
pourquoi on vient travailler et puis
c'est aussi travailler dans de bonnes
conditions
on parle beaucoup de manque de personnel
écoutez je vais être très honnête ainsi
demain vous m'amenez dix mille médecins
et 60 mille infirmières je les prends
c'est pas un problème le recrutement
c'est un problème de postes vacants donc
remplissant les postes vacants voyons
quels sont les besoins et ensuite on les
mettra et pour recruter ces soignants
faut éviter qu'ils quittent les études
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
faut travailler sur la pénibilité faut
travailler sur les conditions de travail
et c'est là dessus que je compte
m'atteler bien entendu dans les mois qui
viennent
l'utilisation du 15 des problèmes de
communication la communication continue
bien entendu mais juste rappeler que
c'est la première fois qu'il ya une
communication nationale depuis que le
numéro 15 existe dans les années 70 il
n'y a jamais eu de communication
nationale sur le bon usage des urgences
est sur le bon usage du 15 donc il va
falloir amené cette cette habitude chez
chesneau chez nos concitoyens et non il
n'ya pas décribilise à sion du 15 je ne
pense pas ni du service d'accès aux
soins ce qui est important c'est son
organisation
le principe du décrocher by niveau mais
on pourra revenir avec ce qui intéresse
qui permettent une réponse à 30 secondes
et une réponse particulièrement
pertinente sur quoi vous avez cité la
vienne et poitiers ça reste pour moi un
exemple le travail qui a été conduit par
le professeur mimosas poitiers sur le
management et et c'est un exemple pour
l'ensemble des services d'urgence de
france qui permet de montrer que ça
fonctionne et quand tout le monde se met
autour de la table quand il ya
effectivement dialogue on arrive à
avancer et bien entendu c'est une
mission d ars de favoriser ce dialogue
comme vous l'avez vu dans l'émission
était au niveau des au niveau des
différents territoires
je répète j'ai déjà dit non le mode ce
n'est pas un mode dégradé d'avoir une
régulation médicale d'avoir une
meilleure orientation des patients c'est
au contraire une meilleure prise en
charge
la santé mentale santé mentale est un
enjeu majeur nous avons fait déjà
beaucoup de choses autour de la santé
mentale la reconnaissance des
psychologues que la possibilité d'avoir
des consultations spécialisées en post
crise qu vides il y à
une épidémie
concernant les pathologies
psychiatriques au sens large chez les
enfants et chez les adolescents là aussi
il ne faut pas méconnaître c'est
d'épidémie et nous allons continuer à
mettre les outils pour pouvoir répondre
le plus possible aux besoins
carence ambulancière je ne reviendrai
pas dessus
la plateforme du 74 c'est un mode de
financement ça rentre dans le cadre des
expérimentations qui sont prévus dans la
loi dite matras et des expérimentations
seront conduites selon les trois modes
l'existence d'une seule plateforme pour
tout l'esprit de service d'urgence
police gendarmerie samu pompiers premier
exemple deuxième exemple la santé d'un
côté les secours et la sécurité de
l'autre et troisième exemple le samu et
les pompiers d'un côté et les la police
de l'autre vous m'avez parlé de ne pas
être allé discuter avec les sapeurs
pompiers dans le cas de la mission flash
c'était une mission de santé qui s'est
adressé aux professionnels de santé les
sapeurs-pompiers sont des professionnels
du secours pour autant ils ont accueilli
très favorablement parce qu'ils m'ont
envoyé les messages les recos étaient 21
ans vous parlez et considère que ça va
tout à fait dans le sens de leurs
revendications que je connais depuis
longtemps
comment comment recruter comment
fidéliser
sur roues 16 et parler de cette co
construction vous avez la solution non
pas de la solution il y en a plusieurs
mais vous avez une solution et j'ai pu
constater en particulier dans les
territoires ruraux lorsque des mers
voulait mettre en place des maisons
médicales et bien quand ils
construisaient la maison médicale et
qu'ils allaient chercher des soignants
après ça marchait pas mais quand ils
construisaient la maison médicale avec
les soignants ça marchait très bien donc
là aussi c'est dans le dialogue et c'est
dans la co construction qu'on va avancer
c'est d'ailleurs bien pour ça que je
souhaite le la conférence des parties
prenantes il y est les soigner les
soignants et les élus parce que c'est
ensemble que nous allons pouvoir trouver
des solutions
les fermetures de maternités dans la
banlieue de lyon oui maternités privées
lucratives qui pour des raisons
comptables a fermé
heureusement il ya le service public qui
est là et c'est à la croix rousse avec
par contre quelque chose d'extrêmement
intéressant et qui n'est pas
expérimental mais qui doit être produit
c'est cette participation cet exercice
mixte des sages femmes qui ont été
récupérés avec un exercice moitié envie
de moitié à l'hôpital c'est vers ça
qu'on doit aller vers ce type de de
faire tomber ce type de barrière pour
que ça avance en ce qui concerne la
scheer desgenettes étant de metz c'est
la même problématique avec lâché à
l'ouest effectivement ça relève du
service de santé des armées qui
reconfigurent pardon son service de
santé pour mieux répondre aux besoins
des armées là aussi on est dans une
réponse de besoin donc il faut à
l'échelle des territoires travail aidé à
aussi tous ensemble on parlait je sais
plus à quel endroit d'un service
d'urgence qui est obligé de fermer
brutalement la nuit etc par pitié porter
au niveau du territoire l'anticipation
de ces problèmes on découvre pas la
veille qu'on n'aura pas la possibilité
de tourner le lendemain et c'est dans
l'anticipation à l'échelle des
territoires avec les hôpitaux au tour
qu'on peut trouver des solutions pour ne
pas pénaliser nos concitoyens voilà
j'espère avoir répondu madame la
présidente à l'ensemble des questions
très très bien monsieur le ministre oui
monsieur le député
saad et monsieur le député a répondu aux
questions vous étiez là effectivement
le monsieur le ministre oui j'ai dit
monsieur le ministre a répondu à toutes
les questions je n'ai pas entendu la
question monsieur le ministre n'a pas
entendu votre question prenait le micro
s'il vous plaît
au ministre s'il veut bien voir
l'amabilité de me donner à lison une
ligne de réponse sur les urgences de
guadeloupe la situation des hôpitaux
doit de loupe du chu le seul chu
merci beaucoup
deux éléments de réponse la première et
c'est pas une réponse positive c'est de
dire qu'être chu ne règle pas le
problème des postes c'est ce qu'un peu
ce que je disais tout à l'heure on a
beau et de chu on peut avoir des
difficultés de recrutement et des
difficultés peuvent les outre-mer ont
les mêmes problèmes que la métropole
déjà non mais déjà les mêmes problèmes
que la métropole et en plus se rajoute
le fait qu'ils sont isolés de parle de
par nationalité et toutes les
difficultés maintenant tu
tout à fait prêt pour travailler avec
vous je les dis depuis le début et avec
les représentants des territoires
d'outre-mer si on peut trouver des
solutions spécifiques pour les outre-mer
je n'en est pas là tout de suite j'ai
des contacts réguliers avec mes
collègues de guadeloupe vous imaginez
bien de martinique de guyane de la
réunion de mayotte pour essayer de voir
quelles solutions on peut mettre en
place un peu plus spécifique
actuellement je ne vois pas de solution
autre que les solutions qui sont mises
en place au niveau national mais si vous
voulez je suis à votre disposition pour
qu'on regarde les problèmes particuliers
très bien monsieur ruffat vous aviez
lever la main oui par accolades de
groupe enfin est-ce que oui ou non vous
planifiez un grand plan d'embûches à
l'hôpital quel sur quelle durée dans
quelle année quel effectif vous voyez
engagés
sur le faire vous étiez malheureusement
pas là quand j'ai répondu
vous avez dû entendre bon
non mais je passais pas une réponse
c'est que on a d'abord des postes
vacants énormément et si on a les
soignants à mettre dessus il ya aucun
problème moi je les embauches demain
vous plaît on écoute monsieur le
ministre je pense que c'est ça la
première réponse après dans le cadre de
la conférence des parties prenantes et
de ma volonté de m'appuyer sur les
besoins de santé non plus sur l'offre
est bien en fonction de l'évaluation des
besoins on augmentera si besoin les
personnels à tel endroit ou à telle
autre parce que on ne doit pas avoir une
vision qui n'est que au niveau de
l'hôpital public malheureusement et pour
connaître de très près la problématique
de 1 explique un opérateur privé et un
hôpital public au même endroit on se
rend compte que si réellement ils
travaillaient ensemble et en particulier
en mettant les mêmes spécialités
ensemble et c'est vers ça que je veux
aller dans le cadre de la refonte du
système sur la réponse aux besoins et
bien on aura là probablement aussi des
meilleures solutions pour le personnel
en qualité de travail et en nombre très
bien monsieur de le goût juste une
petite question en 2016 à l'hôpital nord
de marseille il ya eu une inauguration
pour
donc pour les soins intensifs pour les
adolescents et du coup là on est en 2022
le service il a fermé parce qu'il ya pas
de médecins qui sont intéressés par les
postes et tout le monde fuit cette voie
là ce service et ils vont donc donné
tous les patients à l'hôpital edouard
toulouse qui se situe pas très loin cet
hôpital là nous signifie que ils ont pas
assez de soignants et donc du coup on se
retrouve à laisser des jeunes
adolescents en soin intensif qui ont
besoin de soins psychiatriques notamment
à de voir errer dans les rues et a posé
beaucoup de problèmes dans nos quartiers
je voudrais juste savoir qui c'est qui
en capacité de les prendre en charge et
de savoir s'il n'y a pas la possibilité
que l'unité des soins intensifs pour les
adolescents l'usia qui avait été
inauguré en 2016 peut éventuellement
réouvrir ses portes avec des moyens
importants à l'hôpital nord de marseille
merci
oui merci pour cette question je connais
pas le prime spécifique dont vous parlez
j'ai dit que les problèmes spécifiques
j'étais à la disposition de tout le
monde pour les regarder de près la santé
mentale et est en souffrance c'est moi
qu'on puisse dire santé mentale globale
du dépistage et de la prise en charge
mais vous l'avez dit vous-même
appartement on a plus de soigner entre
les soignants s'en vont ça devient très
difficile de mater des structures
ouvertes à la vraie question c'est
pourquoi ils sont bons est-ce que c'est
par rapport aux conditions de travail
c'est là dessus qu'il faut travailler et
je suis prêt à voir avec vous quelle est
cette problématique est également un
sujet que j'ai sur lequel je n'ai pas
répondu tout à l'heure et je m'en excuse
auprès de monsieur bazin qui était sur
l'intégration de l'inflation en tout cas
la problématique de l'inflation par
rapport par rapport aux ehpad c'est un
c'est un vrai sujet c'est il ya pas de
problème nous avons enfin j'ai rencontré
les différentes fédérations que ce soit
l'hospitalisation privée ou participant
au service public hospitalier enfin les
explique et nous travaillons avec eux là
dessus pour voir comment compenser cette
problématique mais il ne flashent ne
faut pas rajouter de la souffrance le
souffrance et je vous suis tout à fait
là dessus et je ne doute pas qu'avec les
fédérations concernées nous allons
trouver des pistes pour sortir ce de ce
problème
merci bien monsieur le ministre merci
pour effectivement toutes ces réponses
et précision je rappelle quand même que
le sujet c'était les urgences alors il
ya eu quand même ici ou là là l'ancien
enseignant dirait hors sujet mais voilà
tout le monde à nous aurons quand même
l'occasion de d'échanger avec le
ministre dans les mois à venir mais je
tiens à le redire quand même c'était les
urgences alors monsieur ministre merci
d'avoir répondu à l'ensemble des
questions